Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt. Ich bin ein bisschen verletzt, aber ich bin ein bisschen verletzt.
Immer wenn diese Klänge im Radio kommen, ist klar, letzter Mittwoch im Monat Zeit für den Chaos Computer Club und das Chaos Radio. Heute Teil 139, Konz, Starbuck und Henrik sind hier. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz und wir haben heute ein großartiges Thema. Wir reden nämlich über den elektronischen Personalausweis. Es hat niemand auf den Fehlern gelernt hätte. Der letzten Wochen geht das Theater nämlich weiter. Die Kritik am elektronischen Reisepass mit Fingerabdruck und allen Pieperpo ist noch gar nicht verklungen. Die Schlagzeilen zum Thema Datenklau und Datenhandel sind auch noch nicht weg und schon kommt das nächste dicke Ende. Gegen den elektronischen Reisepass könnt ihr euch wehren, wenn ihr sagt, ich fahr nicht weg, ich brauch keinen Pass. Aber einen Ausweis braucht ihr auf jeden Fall und der wird elektronisch lesbar sein. Pflicht wird es ab 1. November 2010, Zeit also den Chaos Computer Club zu versammeln, um dem elektronischen Ausweis mal ein bisschen auf den Pelz zu rücken. Lieber CCC, seid ihr sauer enttäuscht oder habt ihr damit gerechnet, dass das Ding jetzt durchgeht?
Ach, eigentlich sind wir nicht so überrascht, denn die industriepolitischen Förderungsmaßnahmen, werden ja immer vorangetrieben, wurde uns ja auch angekündigt. Wir sind übrigens heute nicht komplett vertreten.
Na ja, aber natürlich seid ihr nicht komplett vertreten. Das wäre ein bisschen voll hier im Studio, aber ihr seid ja quasi der Teil von CCC.
Das war eine echt sehr superschöne Anmoderation.
Und damit haben wir das Thema eigentlich verschlossen. Mehr findet ihr in der Wikipedia. Das war die Sendung für heute. Vielen Dank fürs Musik. Wir reden heute über den elektronischen Ausweis, der ab 2010 Pflicht, also eingeführt wird. Er wird nicht Pflicht sofort. Also ich muss meinen Ausweis dann umtauschen, wenn es soweit ist. Punkt Nummer eins, dann könnt ihr seinen Ausweis jetzt zum Beispiel noch mal verlängern auf 10 Jahre.
Unterschiedlich, je nachdem, wie alt man ist, in der Regel aber 10 Jahre könnte man machen. Und haben wir für einen Reisepass damals ja auch empfohlen.
Aber das ist ja nur eine Verlagerung des Problems. Im Ahnung geht es ja in dem Sinne.
Na ja, hey, vielleicht kann zwischendurch jemand klagen und so. Also eventuell kommt man ja drum rum. Aber bevor es losgeht, müssen wir dringend noch auf etwas anderes hinweisen. Wir sind ja nur hier im schönen Brandenburg, unter anderem.
Da wird nächste Woche gewählt?
Genau. Am 28. September sind Kommunalwahlen und wir haben da doch wieder so ein paar Gemeinden, die haben es sich nicht nehmen lassen, diese unsäglichen manipulationsanfälligen Risikowahlcomputer zu benutzen.
Da gab es doch bei der letzten Kommunalwahl im Cottbus schon Ärger.
Ja, im Cottbus ist es auch wieder dabei. Da freuen wir uns besonders. Die haben offenbar einen neuen Wahlleiter und der ist vollkommen merkbefreit.
Der behauptet, der Fassungsgericht hat schon entschieden.
Er hat im Zeitungsinterview, fälschlicherweise natürlich, also komplett gelogen, gesagt, dass das Bundesfassungsgericht schon entschieden hätte und dass diese Wahlcomputer okay sind. Also eine gezielte Desinformation der Bevölkerung. Ja, und wir fordern mal wieder auf, heraus zu den Wahlen als Wahlbeobachter. Und jeder, der Lust hat und mal auf die Webseite www.ccc.de klicken will, wo er nämlich die Gemeinden findet, die direkt betroffen sind, sind zehn Stück, und er soll sich doch bitte an wahlcomputer.at.ccc.de wenden, und dann wollen wir doch mal sehen, ob wir was schönes beobachten können am 28.
Wir hoffen, dass es gerade geht, aber wie die Vergangenheit gezeigt hat, mit den Wahlcomputern sollte man da speziell sehr skeptisch sein.
Ja klar, aber zunächst mal, jetzt können wir erstmal nichts dagegen machen, außer genau gucken, wie die eingesetzt werden, denn wir wissen ja, die sind manipulationsanfällig, und die Art, wie die eingesetzt werden, sind die einzigen Sicherungen, die wir derzeit haben gegen Manipulationen.
Also schön den entsprechenden Leuten auf die Finger gucken.
Genau, außerdem gibt es natürlich noch die Klagungen bei Munster-Pfanns-Gericht und irgendwie alle zusätzlichen Informationen, die wir erfinden, also alle Schwächen, die wir irgendwie aufdecken können, wären natürlich hilfreich sein nachher bei der Entscheidung.
Genau, also wir haben...
Also ein Dienst an der Demokratie sozusagen.
Also schön, ihr seid auf Starbucks.
Dafür muss man auch um 6 Uhr aufstehen.
Ja, aber dann kannst du später nicht sagen, ich beschwere mich, aber ich kann nichts dafür tun.
Also ich habe es auch schon gemacht, und werde später meinen Kindern erzählen können, ich habe die Demokratie gerettet.
Das ist durchaus interessant. Also man lernt dabei, was die meisten Leute wissen, wie wählen geht, aber nicht, was da eigentlich drumherum passiert. Also das ist durchaus auch spannend.
Also Kommunalwahlen in Brandenburg nächste Woche, ein Thema, was mit Aufmerksamkeit beobachtet wird. Zum zweiten kriegt ihr heute auch Informationen über das anstehende Blinkenleitz und auch den Datengarten. Das machen wir dann am Ende der Sendung. Aber jetzt könnten wir eigentlich zum Thema von Chaosradio 139 kommen. Mit der schönen Unterschrift Biometrische Ausweisdokumente. Jetzt erfassen wir alle. Weil ein Ausweis braucht ja jeder. Grundsätzlich Problem Nummer eins. Es gibt einen elektronisch lesbaren Ausweis. Wenn dich jetzt sagen, wenn Bundesinnenminister wäre, ist er super. Gibt es weniger Papier, ist alles viel einfacher. Kann Frau Müller an ihrem Computer auf den Knopf drücken und weiß sofort, ob der Herr Krause seinen Ausweis richtig drin hat und es doch alles schnafte. Wo ist das Problem? Jetzt redet Konz einfach zwei Stunden durch.
Im Wesentlichen ist natürlich ein Problem, weil wir haben die technische Umsetzung und vor allem aber auch der verpflichtende Einsatz der Biometrie. Denn zwar sind die Fingerabdrücke für diesen Personalausweis nicht verpflichtend, sondern zunächst erstmal freiwillig.
Das heißt, ich muss nicht?
Nein, aber dafür ist das biometrische Gesichtsbild jetzt verpflichtend. Und wir haben vor allen Dingen auch ziemlich starke Kritikpunkte daran, dass aus diesem hoheitlichen Dokument, was man eben haben muss, um sich auszuweisen, dass jetzt plötzlich so eine Art Dienstleistungs- und Servicekarte für die Industrie wird.
Wieso, was heißt das?
Denn ja, es sind einige neue Funktionen, die da eingeführt werden. Insbesondere halt für die Identifizierung. Also, die man auch nicht alle nehmen muss. Man kann die halt nehmen als Bürger. Man kann sagen, ja bitte aktivieren. Oder auch nicht. Aber es soll eben zur leichteren Identitätsfeststellung etwa im Geschäftsverkehr online.
Was das für Dinge im Detail sind, das klären wir sowieso noch. Frage gleich mal wieder reingeschossen. Du hast gesagt, man kann die aktivieren, man muss aber nicht. Wenn ich mich jetzt hinstelle und sage, Herr Kranz braucht einen neuen Ausweis, kann ich sagen, ich möchte keine Fingerabdrücke da drin und ich möchte auch keine Freischaltung für irgendwas. Ist ja eigentlich erstmal cool. Dann bin ich aber irgendwo auf www.einkaufenfetz.de und die sagen mir, wir brauchen aber hier ihren Ausweis, ihren Zugang, um damit sie bei uns einkaufen können. Dann bin ich doch Nese. Also, theoretisch würde doch jeder, jedes Bürgeramt und jeder Händler zu mir kommen und sagen, machtet das ganz toll.
Deswegen ist diese Freiwilligkeit auch irgendwie ziemlich, also eigentlich eine Pseudofreiwilligkeit, weil natürlich wird sich über kurz über lang irgendwie sämtliche Händler darauf umstellen, diese Identifizierung im Internet kaufen, mit dem Ausweis zu machen. Und im Endeffekt hast du nicht wirklich eine Wahl. Genau das Gleiche ist auch bei dem Fingerabdruck. Natürlich sagen sie jetzt, es ist erstmal freiwillig, aber Politiker sagen uns das auch mehr oder weniger indirekt. Und es ist eigentlich allen klar, dass spätestens, also ich würde sagen nach der nächsten Wahl, oder wenn sie irgendwann mal wieder schlecht drauf sind, diese Freiwilligkeit natürlich in den Verpflichtungen umschlagen wird. Das ist einfach schon abzusehen.
Es gibt halt nur eine Ausnahme, die jetzt noch diskutiert wird. Nämlich Bürger, die über 75 Jahre alt sind. Weil davon ausgegangen wird, dass die neuen Funktionen in diesem elektronischen Personalausweis, die ohnehin überfordern würden. Und daher sollen die nicht so wirklich dazugehören. Und die brauchen dann auch keinen neuen Personalausweis beantragen.
Das heißt, mein Opa kann dann gar nicht mehr Power Seller bei Dingsbums werden?
Na ja, er könnte wohl schon. Aber die haben halt einfach längere Laufzeiten, weil tatsächlich begründet wird, die seien eh überfordert und würden diese Funktionen nicht benutzen.
Wir werden das sicher noch im Detail klären. Bislang ist es ja so, Internet einkaufen, Legitimation bedeutet, ich kaufe irgendwas ein, gebe meine Kreditkartennummer an oder sowas. Und dann checken die das bei der Bank gegen, ob die Kreditkartennummer stimmt und ob der Name zu den Dingen gehört. Dann kriege ich eine Rechnung. Und es gibt laut Fernmeldung, Absatzgesetz, einfach ein Wiederrufsrecht, wenn ich irgendwas geschickt bekomme und sage, habe ich nicht bestellt, schicke ich es zurück. Fertig. Wie läuft es denn dann?
Zunächst muss sich der Verbraucher wahrscheinlich darauf gefasst machen, dass er sich Zusatzgeräte besorgen muss, damit er eben zu Hause diese Identifikationsfunktionen benutzen kann.
Also da ist auch gleich der erste oder der nächste Haken, dass diese Systeme, also sie preisen sie zwar an, für, wird jeder haben, wird irgendwie fünf Euro kosten, aber das wird definitiv nicht der Fall sein. Also wir rechnen so auf jeden Fall mit irgendwie knapp, also knapp dreistellig. Also es wird halt schon irgendwie über 100 Euro kosten, weil es ist einfach mal ein Sicherheits-Device, wo halt relativ viel Hardware drin ist, was irgendwie auch zertifiziert sein muss und so weiter. Also da ist auf jeden Fall Zusatzkosten, also es wird nicht an den, bei den 60 Euro für den Ausweis bleiben.
Also sie hoffen natürlich auf die Industrie, der IT-Direktor. Sie hoffen, dass es nach und nach ein bisschen billiger wird und sie hoffen, dass so Geräte für 10, 15 Euro auf den Markt kommen, für die Verbraucher. Aber das wird wahrscheinlich eine Weile dauern.
Okay, also ihr habt ja gemerkt, es gibt einen Haufen Sachen zu erzählen und zu erklären rund um diesen elektronischen Ausweis. Darum wird es heute gehen. Wenn ihr Fragen habt, könnt ihr hier gerne anrufen, 0331 70 97 110 oder aber auch mailen an chaosradio at ccc.de. Wir versuchen das alles abzuarbeiten.
Wir haben eigentlich eine Frage, die wir den Hörern gerne stellen wollen. Nämlich, es sind ja nun schon einige Zeit diese Reisepässe im Umlauf. Wir würden eigentlich ganz gerne mal wissen, wer mal einen beantragt hat in den letzten zwei Jahren, ob er vielleicht mal berichten mag, wie das war. Vor allen Dingen, wenn er schon Fingerabdrücke im Reisepass hat. Ob er vielleicht mal einfach aus dem realen Leben erzählen will, wie das so abgelaufen ist in seinem Meldeamt.
Okay, also eure Erfahrung mit dem elektronischen Reisepass, den dann alle anderen mit dem elektronischen Ausweis übernehmen können, unter 0331 70 97 110. Ganz viel Gelaber wird es auch nicht geben. Wir haben ein bisschen schicke Musik. Komm, wollen wir jetzt gleich, wir bloggen sie weg, spielen? Oder wollen wir jetzt was anderes spielen? Jetzt kommt Weltherrscher mit Wir bloggen sie weg. Und danach reden wir weiter über den elektronischen Ausweis im Chaos Radio auf Fritz.
Das Nuw, Spreeblick, Bildblog, X der Wirre, MC Winkel, Thomas Knüger und das Lawblog, Jens Scholz, Madame Modeste, Anke Gröner und die Werbeblogger.
Eine musikalische Großtat vom Weltherrscher zu finden unter www.dieweltistscheiße.de oder einfach nach Weltherrscher suchen. Und da gibt es auch diesen, wir bloggen sie weg. Chaosradio auf Ritzteil 131. Konz, Starbuck und Henrik sind hier vom CCC. Mein Name ist Jakob Kranz. Wir reden über den elektronischen Ausweis, der dem nichts ansteht und der jeden von uns betrifft, der irgendwie über das Alter hinaus ist, wo man einen Ausweis braucht. Einen Ausweis braucht ihr in jedem Fall. Quasi der kleine Bruder vom elektronischen Reisepass. Und den hat Christoph schon. Hallo Christoph, guten Abend.
Wie war's denn?
Ich lese relativ viel Chaosradio, Blog und bei Kyle Raven und so und war rechtzeitig informiert, auf den letzten möglichen Drücker noch vorbeizugehen und mir so einen alten Reisepass zu holen. Also alten heißt, mit dem biometrischen Bild habe ich schon. Keine Fingerabdrücke, da habe ich extra darauf geachtet. Und ich war auch extra zweieinhalb Monate nicht beim Friseur. Ich habe an dem Tag vorher wenig geschlafen, damit ich möglichst gleich aussehe. Und habe die Brille falsch aufgesetzt.
Also du siehst so aus, wie du immer aussiehst. Genau, so aus, wie ich immer aussiehe. Wie ein... Nein, das sage ich jetzt nicht.
Was heißt denn, das Gesichtsbild, was du abgegeben hast, ist so ein bisschen, naja, nicht eben wie du selbst wirklich aussiehst.
Nein, tatsächlich nicht.
Ich glaube nicht, dass das eine Software rendern kann.
Weil wenn man nämlich den Kopf nach vorne legt, dann fällt das nicht so auf. Allerdings verzerren sich dann die Bildproportionen.
Ja, natürlich.
Also ich hab den Tag zelebriert.
Aber was ist dir denn mit der Mikrowelle passiert?
Mikrowelle? Ja, das war auf dem Nachhauseweg. Da bin ich nämlich noch, weil mir der Magen so knurrte und die Unimensa schon zu hatte, dann noch schnell in den nächstbesten Supermarkt und hab mir eine Tiefkühlpizza, eine Lasagne gekauft. Und jetzt hab ich die aus Versehen in dieselbe Tüte reingepackt, wo schon der Reisepass drin war. Und der muss irgendwie, weil das so kalt war und so, dann unten festgeklebt sein. Ja, nee, also total schlimm.
Du vermute, dass der Chip jetzt nicht mehr funkt, oder?
Ja doch, der hat noch gefunkt. Also wie ich nämlich die Lasagne in die Mikrowelle reinzumacht, nach drei Sekunden, ich denk, was denn da passiert, machst du mal aus und dann klebt dir da der Reisepass drunter.
Aber Christoph, was mich jetzt an der Stelle viel mehr interessiert, die Geschichte ist natürlich sehr tragisch, aber wenn man also eine Lasagne oder welches Fertiggericht noch immer kauft, ist das ja in einer sogenannten Assiette. Also so eine Alufolie und rundherum ist auch eine schöne bunte Verpackung, auf der die Lasagne so aussieht, wie sie nie aussehen wird, wenn sie auf deinem Teller landet. Wenn du jetzt aber den Pass in deine Tüte steckst und der klebt dir da dran, du hast hoffentlich die Lasagne aus dieser Pappschachtel rausgenommen, weil sonst hoffentlich du hast das nicht hier essen. Nur mal so nebenbei.
Also die Lasagne ist doch, ich hab die, die hab ich, also die war in so einer Pappschachtel oder so.
Also nur für den Fall, dass dir jetzt der Chip dabei kaputtgegangen sein sollte, dann würde das ja nichts ausmachen, denn dein Reisepass wäre ja weiterhin ein gültiges Dokument, genauso wie der beim elektronischen Personalausweis sein wird.
Ja, da freu ich mich nämlich, weil nachdem das nämlich gefunkt hat, hab ich mir gedacht, mhm, was ist denn das? Hab die Lasagne rausgenommen und auf den ersten Blick den Reisepass unten drunter nicht entdeckt, die Lasagne wieder reingetan und noch mal drei Sekunden bei 80 Watt, die auftauen lassen.
Eine Frage, die im Video zur Sendung schon auftauchte, was passiert, wenn der Chip kaputt geht, mit welchen Folgen muss man rechnen?
Ja, die Folgen sind genau Null, denn Paßgesetz wie auch im Personalausweisgesetz ist natürlich festgelegt, dass wenn der Chip defekt ist, diese Dokument gültig bleibt.
Christoph, also du musst dir keine Sorgen machen. Die einzige Sorge, die wir uns machen, wenn du so viel fertig Lasagne isst, das ist natürlich nicht gesund. Es ist ein bisschen mehr Obst, ne?
Oh, ich hoffe, er hat mich aufgelegt.
Ich hatte den Kopf in die Mikrowelle gesteckt.
Nein, wir wollten nur noch mal anmerken. Danke für die Geschichte. Das ist natürlich sehr tragisch. Nicht so viel Lasagne essen ist nicht gesund, vielleicht ein bisschen mehr Obst, ne?
Das war die einzige Lasagne, die ich da kaufte in dem ganzen Jahr.
Fein, fein, fein, fein. Sehr schön. Danke dir, Christoph. Und am Telefon ist Patrick. Hallo Patrick, grüß dich.
Ja, grüß euch.
Hallo, ist dir sowas ähnliches passiert wie dem Christoph? Mit einer Lasagne?
Nein, nein. Ich hab keinen Reisepass beantragt. Aber mein Bruder, der musste halt nach Aminant wegen Freundin, ist auch alles nichts mehr mit der Freundin, aber jedenfalls hat er so einen Reisepass beantragt. Und brauchte halt dieses biometrische Bild.
Aber noch keine Fingerdrücke, sondern nur das Bild.
Ich meine, er musste auf Phishing abgeben damals. Jedenfalls geht er zum Fotografen, macht das Bild, kommt zur Passstelle da und will das abgeben. Und die so, ja, lächeln zu viel. Nochmal, also dann hat der Fotograf das wohl nochmal gemacht. Auch noch aus Kranz. Kommt mit dem Bild halt wieder zur Passstelle. Die sagen, die außen sind krumm.
Okay, das heißt zweimal ist er durch den Check sozusagen gefallen.
Ja genau, und dann ist er mit dem Bild nochmal zum Fotografen. Der hat gesagt, gar kein Problem, der hatte wohl keinen Bock mehr. Hat Photoshop geöffnet, hat das Bild nachbearbeitet. Und mit dem Bild, wo die Augen dann gerade gerückt wurden, ist mein Bruder dann durchgekommen.
Das ist ja super, damit ist er zwar biometrisch nicht mehr erkennbar, aber hat für die Software ein gutes biometrisches Bild abgegeben.
Genau, das wurde halt akzeptiert, weil die Augen waren gerade gerückt. Und dann war das alles wunderbar.
Das zeigt aber wieder mal ganz typisch die Sinnlosigkeit dieser biometrischen Erfassung, weil halt genau sein realer Kopf natürlich irgendwie nicht biometrisch erfassbar war. Und wenn er jetzt an die Grenze kommt, wird jedes System sagen, das ist aber nicht die gleiche Person, die irgendwie sein Passbild damals in den Ausweis gesteckt hat. Aber das System war erst mal zufrieden und das Deutsche Beamten auch.
Aber was mach ich in so einem Fall, wenn ein Grenzbeamter zu mir sagt, das sind nicht Sie? Also zumindest sagt mein Computer, dass Sie das nicht sind.
Naja, das kann er natürlich dann schon...
Das Bild hat ja wohl gefallen. Also die Leute auf dem Amt waren halt nicht geschult, um zu wissen, wie das halt dann funktioniert mit den biometrischen Bildern.
Nee, das war ganz normal das Vorgehen. Also wenn...
Der ist mit dem Bild nach Arminland gereist und da hat sich niemand beschwert.
Das hat andere Gründe. In der Regel ist es so, dass in Amerika bisher der europäische Pass noch nicht ausgelesen wird, also damit auch der deutsche. Es gibt jetzt bei den ersten Flughäfen diese Auslesegeräte, aber in der Regel nehmen die ja dann wieder ein Live-Bild. Und für den Menschen, der sich das Bild anguckt, für den ist das ja egal.
Wenn ihr halt wirklich an die Grenze kommt und sie halt überprüfen, ob das Bild passt jetzt mit dem real aufgenommenen Bild übereinstimmt, also wenn das die Software macht, dann wird die halt schon feststellen, dass das halt nicht die gleiche Person ist, weil das Bild halt irgendwie gestaucht wurde.
Ja, im Grunde, wenn das denn mal so weit sein wird an den Grenzen, kann das schon sein, dass er danach öfter mal überprüft wird. Aber das kann einem natürlich tatsächlich passieren, wenn man einfach so ein biometrisch nicht akzeptables Bild hat für die Software, dann muss man halt damit leben. Das ist ja auch gerade diese Diskriminierung, die wir so unschön finden an diesem Pass.
Also wir haben die Lösung dafür. Er wird einfach, genau wie vorher, den Ausweis in die Mikrowelle stecken bzw. den Chip disablen und damit halt dieses falsche Foto einfach aus der Realität tegen.
Die Frage ist eigentlich, ob sowas schon ein Fälschungsversuch ist und damit strafbar, wenn man das Bild bearbeitet. Das müssen wir mal juristisch checken lassen. Aber wir fragen mal nicht nach deinem Namen.
Aber die Behörde hat es ja angenommen. Sie wollten ja das richtige Bild nicht haben.
Aber auf jeden Fall, wenn ein Jurist zuhört, also an Juristen hätten wir auf jeden Fall noch ein paar Fragen, interessante Fragen in dem Zusammenhang.
Ja, und dann wollte ich noch erzählen, ich war auf der CeBIT 2007 oder?
Wir sind mal 2008. Also fast schon 2009.
Ja genau, 2007 war ich auf der CeBIT, hab mir da mal den Stand der Bundesbrukeri angeguckt, dann hat man geguckt, was die ja jetzt immer noch an neuen Sachen da entwickeln. Die wollen da ja organische Verbindungen mit reinbringen in die Reisepässe, die halt irgendwie chiptechnisch arbeiten und so. Ich hab den Typen einfach mal gefragt, wie das denn ist von den Kosten.
Er hat gesagt, ja, kostet halt 60 Euro.
Ich hab gesagt, früher waren die Pässe billiger. Ich hab keine 120 Mark bezahlt für meinen Passt.
Was hat er gesagt?
Er hat gesagt, ja, dann müssen sich die Leute aus der Technik wenden. Aber im Prinzip hat er mein Problem eingesehen.
Er hat gesagt, ja, das stimmt schon. Also 60 Euro zahl ich für den Passt.
20 nochmal für dieses Bild, das sind 80 Euro.
Es ist ja schon so, dass der biometrische Reisepass sich natürlich mit der Einführung des Gesichtsbilds verdoppelt hat. Das heißt, vorher hat er 30 Euro gekostet, jetzt kostet er 60. Also es ist halt schon toll geworden.
Weil das Bild nochmal 20 kostet.
Also immerhin hat er nicht zu dir gesagt, hey, kaufen sie doch Aktien von unserem Unternehmen. War er doch noch nett.
Ja, nee, also ich wollte einfach nochmal von der Bundesdrucke weiter eine Aussage kräftigen. Die hatten halt einen zweiten Stand. Und darauf hat er mich verwiesen. Ich hab dann mal wegen Sicherheit bequatscht und so. Wollte halt wissen, was da so Sache ist. Und er hat sich halt zu diesen ganzen marketingtechnischen Sachen nicht geäußert.
Also wir waren ja letztes Jahr auf der CeBIT auch beim Stand der Bundesdrucke rein, haben uns da auch sehr lange und sehr intensiv unterhalten. Und da ging es halt hauptsächlich um die Fingerabdrücke. Und ihre Aussage, also die Kernaussage, die uns halt auch wirklich vom Hocker gerissen hat, war, dass sie die Fingerabdrücke in den Pass reinschreiben, egal welche Qualität sie haben. Das heißt eigentlich, Biometrie funktioniert halt so, dass man einen Vergleich zwischen dem Referenzbild und dem live aufgenommen Bild macht. Und wenn dann halt einen gewissen Schwerwert überschreitet, dann wird es halt irgendwie akzeptiert oder nicht. Wenn es überschritten wird, wird es akzeptiert. Und was sie gesagt haben, ist, dass die Qualitätswerte in den Meldeämtern, also dass die Fingerabdrücke auch aufgenommen werden, wenn die Qualitätswerte halt irgendwie eigentlich null sind.
Sie haben die da angeguckt und angestarrt und haben gedacht, was, damit ist natürlich auch diese ganze Versprochene, dieser Sicherheit zu gewinnen, absolut sinnfrei.
Das heißt, wenn ich mit dreckigen Fingern kommen, oder aber mir gerade an einer heißen Herdplatte den Finger verbrannt habe und die Haut nachwächst, dann nehmen sie es trotzdem, oder wie?
Wir haben da gerade eine sehr schöne Live-Geschichte gehabt.
Folgender Vorschlag zur Güte. Schöne Live-Geschichte, Biometrie und so weiter und so fort. Wir steuern mit großen, großen Schritten auf die Nachrichten zu. Lass uns die Nachrichten machen und danach tiefer ins Thema Biometrie einsteigen. Das ist für alle Beteiligten cool? Alles klar. Patrick, dir vielen Dank und schöne Grüße an deinen Bruder. Tschüss.
Zwischen Samstag und Montag kommt bei Fritz der Soundtag. Der Sonntag auf Fritz mit dem extra langen Fritz Soundgarden. Von 10 bis 14 Uhr. Und dem neuesten aus der neuen Fritz-Musik der kommenden Woche. Mit Ken FN von 14 bis 18 Uhr. Und Live-Musik von jungen Bands, die noch kaum jemand kennt.
Und mit Unsigned.
Wo die muss noch geöffnet werden. Und neuer Musik, noch ganz runde Plattenvertrag. Aber von hier und da, wo sie passiert. Der extra lange Soundgarden. 10 bis 14. Ken FN. 14 bis 18. Und Unsigned. 18 bis 20 Uhr.
Und das hört man... Fritz-Info. Nachricht.
Und wenn ich die Uhr lesen könnte, würde ich sagen halb 11. Fritz-Info.
Eine Tag vor der Großdemonstration gegen die finanzielle Situation der Krankenhäuser in Deutschland hat die Bundesregierung mehr Geld beschlossen. Es geht um 3 Milliarden Euro. Den Klinikbetreibern reicht das nicht. Sie sehen die flächendeckende Versorgung und Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr. Krankenkassen kritisieren, dass ausschließlich die Beitragszahler durch höhere Sätze für das Milliardenpaket der Bundesregierung aufkommen müssten. Alle sieben Vorstandsmitglieder der KfW-Bank sind wegen Untreue angezeigt worden. Das teilte die Staatsanwaltschaft in Frankfurt am Main mit. Die KfW hatte der US-Bank Lehman Brothers 350 Millionen Euro überwiesen, obwohl das US-Institut zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon zahlungsunfähig war. Den beiden suspendierten Vorständen werden nach KfW-Angaben ihre Bezüge von insgesamt 600.000 Euro weitergezahlt. Wer sich beruflich verbessern und aufsteigen will, soll besser gefördert werden. Die Bundesregierung hat dafür heute die Regelungen zum Meister-Bafik geändert. In Zukunft bezahlt der Staat bei erfolgreicher Abschlussprüfung fast die Hälfte der Kurs- und Prüfungsgebühren. Bisher ist es knapp ein Drittel. Außerdem sollen neben Handwerkern und anderen Fachkräften jetzt auch Altenpfleger und Erzieher bei der Fortbildung finanziell unterstützt werden. Bundesjustizministerin Zypries hat sich für eine vollständige Gleichstellung von homosexuellen Paaren ausgesprochen. Das sei in einer modernen Gesellschaft ein Gebot der Toleranz, sagte sie in Berlin. Ihr Ministerium untersuche derzeit die Möglichkeit einer gemeinsamen Adoption fremder Kinder Zwar gäbe es in wichtigen Gebieten wie dem Familienrecht bereits erhebliche Fortschritte im Steuer- und Beamtenrecht, müssten aber Ungleichheiten abgebaut werden. Hertha BSC hat das Achtelfinale des DFB-Pokals verpasst. Die Berliner verloren am Abend bei Borussia Dortmund nach Verlängerung mit 1 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen potzt am Frankfurt-Wittenberg an der Münde 10 Grad, Cottbus Neuropin 11 Grad und auch in Berlin sind es so zwischen 10 bis 11 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es stellenweise bewirkt, in einigen Gegenden gibt es auch einen sternenklaren Himmel. Es bleibt heute Nacht aber überall trocken, die Tiestätte heute dann bis zu 6 Grad. Morgen wird es wieder sonnig, ohne Regen und das bei Höchstwerten von angenehmen 18 Grad. Es ist noch einiges los auf den Straßen. A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt oder zwischen Storkow und Fürstenwalde West gibt es eine Baustelle und immer noch 7 Kilometer Stau. A24 Hamburg Richtung Berlin zwischen Pritzwalk und dem Dreieck Wittstock-Dosse gibt es Behinderungen durch ein kaputtes Fahrzeug. A114 Zubringer Pankow statt auswärts zwischen Schönerlinder Straße und dem Dreieck Pankow liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Dadurch kommt es auch dort zu Behinderungen und eine Meldung aus dem Stadtverkehr Berlin. A115 AWUS Zubringer Nutetal statt auswärts Richtung Dreieck Potsdam zwischen Dreieck Funktum und dem Bittenweg ist die rechte Spur gesperrt, dort wird gebaut. Ansonsten euch eine gute Fahrt. Pritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz im Raum Angermünde.
Die Zeitsprechstunden.
HaHa, die fabulöse Emiliana Torini aus Island im Chaosradio auf Fritz, 24. September. Konz, Starwag und Henrik sind da. Wir reden über den elektronischen Personalausweis. Der Begriff Biometrie ist jetzt sehr oft gefallen. Starwag müsste dazu vielleicht noch ein paar Anmerkungen loswerden.
Genau, also wir gehen einfach noch mal kurz zurück zum elektronischen Reisepass, der ja was Biometrie betrifft die gleichen Sachen beinhaltet, wie der elektronische Personalausweis in Zukunft. Und da wir gerade bei der Sache mit den schlechten Fingerabdrücken sind, habe ich gerade mal eine Geschichte zu erzählen, die jemanden passiert ist vor kurzem. Dieinige hat sich einen Reisepass beantragt und da sie halt irgendwie ihre Fingerabdrücke nicht abgeben wollte, hat sie Folgendes getan. Sie hat sich einfach Sekundenkleber auf die Fingerabdrücke gemacht und ist damit dann zum Meldamt gegangen.
Der geht ja auch so schwer wieder ab, der Sekundenkleber.
Der geht es, da kommen wir gleich noch zu, dass er schwer wieder abgeht. Auf jeden Fall ging sie halt rein und kam halt zu der ersten Meldstellenbeamtin, die halt erstmal ganz verdutzt war, weil halt keine Fingerabdrücke auf ihrem System zu sehen waren, hat dann das System erst mal zweimal rebooted und als immer noch keine Fingerabdrücke da waren, hat sie ihren Kollegen geholt, die ja das Gleiche versucht hat. Dann sind sie noch am Nachbartisch gegangen, wo irgendwie auch keine Fingerabdrücke zu sehen waren. Dann haben sie die gute Frau zum Händewaschen geschickt. Das heißt, sie haben sie tatsächlich aufgefordert, mal irgendwie zur Kaffeetassenspüle zu gehen und sich die Hände zu waschen. Als das auch nicht geholfen hat und sie immer noch keine Fingerabdrücke auf dem Sensor hinterlassen haben, haben sie dann den Meldestellen-Obermufti geholt, der sich die Finger angeguckt hat und auf die Aussage, ja die glänzen ja so ein bisschen, war halt die Antwort der jungen Dame, dass sie halt irgendwie täglich mit Chemikalien zu tun hätte und deswegen das halt so ist. Und dann hat er endlich nach einer halben Stunde eingesehen, dass sie wirklich keine Fingerabdrücke hat und ihr einen Reisepass ohne Fingerabdrücke ausgestellt.
Denn die Software hat so einen Knopf, den keine Fingerknopf. Das heißt der Meldestellenbeamte kann sagen, dieser Reisepass-Beantragte hat keine Fingerabdrücke.
Das heißt man kann sehr wohl auch beim Reisepass die Fingerabdruckabgabe noch umgehen und das funktioniert auch.
Ja.
Wieder was gelernt.
Ja, wir fahren die Aktion doch aus, ich brauch ein Kuhl.
Der nächste am Telefon ist Sebastian. Hallo Sebastian, guten Abend.
Grüß dich.
Du hast eine Frage?
Es geht auf das Thema Industrie und zurück und die Begehrlichkeiten, was jetzt diese Gesichtserkennung und allgemeine Biometrie angeht. Ihr wart ja, weiß ich, einmütig feste Überzeugung, dass jetzt bei, sag mal, Online-Einkauf oder so solche Dinge auch schon direkt abgefragt würden. Das sehe ich generell etwas anders.
Erklär mal genauer.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, dass irgendwie Fingerabdrücke, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie es übertragen wird.
Nee, die Fingerabdrücke gar nicht. Da ist es bisher so, dass geregelt werden wird, dass nur der Staat Zugriff darauf haben wird. Auf keinen Fall die Industrie, im Gegensatz bisher.
Also du kaufst nicht irgendwo ein paar Socken und musst deinen Fingerabdruck deswegen abgeben.
Die biometrischen Daten sind nur für hoheitliche Zwecke gedacht und können nur von hoheitlichen Systemen abgefragt werden.
Also es ist natürlich schon so, dass wir derzeit sehen, dass sich elektronische Identitätsnachweisverfahren langsam durchsetzt und es gibt eine ganze Menge Anwendungen in der Industrie. Das heißt, die Industrie bereitet sich darauf schon vor. Aber momentan wird darüber nicht debattiert.
Mir wäre es mich nur sehr überrascht, wenn es irgendwie bei einem Einkauf oder bei der Finanzierung, bei der Kontoeröffnung etc. zusammen mit dem Ausweis abgefragt würde. Das könnte ich mir überhaupt nicht vorstellen.
Also für die Zukunft wollen wir das sicherlich auch nicht ausschließen, weil Fingerabdrücke schon ein ziemlich gutes Merkmal sind, um Personen zu identifizieren. Es ist zwar derzeit nicht geplant, aber kann man sich durchaus...
Aber wie genau läuft denn diese Identifizierung über diesen neuen elektronischen Ausweis? Was genau, das ist ja auch die Frage von Sebastian, was genau sind denn diese abzufragenden Daten, die ich zu Hause mit den zusätzlich zu kaufenden Geräten dann an irgendjemanden sende, um klarzustellen, ich bin es wirklich?
Also, dieser neue einzuführende elektronische Personalausweis besteht im Wesentlichen aus zwei bis drei Bestandteilen. Zum einen haben sie eingebaut etwas, was fast, also vollständig identisch zu einem bisherigen elektronischen Reisepass funktioniert und aussieht. Das heißt also dieselben Sicherheitsfunktionsweisen, wie der zurzeit ausgegebene elektronische Reisepass hat. Dann haben sie etwas eingebaut, was sie elektronischen Identitätsnachweis nennen, abgekürzt EID.
Und was ist das?
Da drin sind nicht die biometrischen Daten gespeichert, sondern zum einen die Informationen zum Ausweisinhaber, also Name, Adresse, Geburtsdatum, Schuhgröße vielleicht auch nicht.
Ausweisnummer?
Dann Informationen zum Dokument, also Dokumententyp, Ausweisnummer, Ablaufdatum. Und das reicht glaube ich auch erstmal.
Ok, also das sind diese Daten, die online abgefragt werden können.
Genau und optional kann man noch eine qualifizierte elektronische Signatur aufbringen. Das wäre dann die dritte Anwendung, die auf der gleichen Karte implementiert ist.
Was genau ist diese qualifizierte elektronische Signatur?
Das ist das, was man jetzt schon haben kann. Das ist also eine elektronische Signatur, die dann vollständig equivalent zur eigenhändigen Unterschrift sein soll.
Also muss ich irgendwo auf einem Board unterschreiben?
Nein, eine digitale Signatur, also mit PIN, mit Karte und PIN. Das muss man sich aber extra kaufen, das kostet auch extra.
Also das sind diese Geräte, von denen Starbuck sprach. Also ich brauche irgendein Gerät, wo ich ein PIN eingeben kann, mit einer speziellen Karte.
Genau, für eine ordentlich qualifizierte elektronische Signatur. Ich weiß nicht, ob das vorgeschrieben ist, aber man will ein extra PIN-Pad haben, sodass man die PIN nicht auf der Computer-Tastatur eingeben kann.
Das soll wirklich der Ersatz für eine Unterschrift im digitalen Zeitalter sein. Also dass jeder nicht mehr irgendwie hingeht, wirklich unterschreiben muss, sondern die Karte reinsteckt, seine PIN eingibt und damit praktisch beweist, dass er den Willen hatte, das irgendwie zu tun.
Siehst du, Sebastian, also keine Fingerabdrücke beim Schuh kaufen.
Das ist sowieso nicht Schuhe kaufen. Das ist halt Vertragsunterzeichnungen, Versicherungen abschließen. Das hast du nicht gesehen.
Und wenn ich 500 Paar Schuhe kaufe?
Zum Einkaufen ist gedacht, das sind halt diese diversen feuchten Träume, die sie haben, die ja elektronischen Identitätsnachweis, dass also der Pass mit einem fremden System, irgendwo mit der Bank oder mit der Bank, mit eBay, mit irgendjemandem auf der anderen Seite im Internet kommuniziert und dem bestimmte Informationen gibt.
Also es läuft prinzipiell so ab, dass es halt, wer daran teilnehmen will, also welcher Händler, muss halt ein Zertifikat beantragen von der BSI, ist das glaube ich, da die Zertifikat ausstellt. Und in dem Zertifikat steht auch gleichzeitig drin, welche Informationen er dann von dem Benutzer, von dem Käufer verlangen darf. Also halt Adresse im Regelfall, weil muss er da hinschicken.
Oder nur alter geht auch, etwa bei Porno-Anbietern.
Genau gesagt, nicht alter, sondern bist du schon 18.
Genau, also dieses Fleck, wie bist du schon 18 gibt es halt auch. Also halt wirklich, dass der Beantrager dieses Zertifikats sagt, ich will dem jetzt Pornos verkaufen und muss deswegen wissen, wo er wohnt und ob er über 18 ist. Und dann stellt das BSI, dem hat die Zertifizierung aus. Und wenn der Käufer dann halt irgendwie daraufklickt, dann wird er halt gefragt, steck jetzt dein Ausweischen bitte ein und dann gib noch deine PIN ein. Und dann darfst du auswählen, welche Daten du ihm senden willst. Das heißt, du darfst ihm auch mehr Daten senden, wenn du lustig bist. Aber halt in der Regel sendet man die Daten, die halt irgendwie drauf angefragt wurden.
Aha, siehst du Sebastian, jetzt ist die Frage beantwortet.
Ich denke auch. Es ist nur eine Sache noch, ich würde jetzt nicht sagen, dass das irgendwie zwingend durchgesetzt wird, kann ich mir nicht vorstellen, weil es kommt sicherlich der Tag, wo dann ich einen Vertrag abschließen soll und die machen mir ein Angebot für eine Versicherung oder sowas. Ich geh zu denen hin und die sagen mir, ja wir brauchen den elektronischen Nachweis, dann sag ich denen, tschüss, ich bin beim anderen Anbieter. Die Macht des Kunden ist immer noch relativ stark. Und da wird sich der Anbieter zu auch sowas einlassen, sowas anzubieten, also elektronischer Nachweis.
Aber er wird den Kunden nicht deswegen verlieren wollen.
Er wird nicht vorschreiben, weil der Umsatz dabei würden.
Ich fürchte, du lebst in einer Traumwelt, das wird so nicht passieren.
Ich glaube auch, dass sich die meisten Verbraucher ihrer Macht als Konsumenten überhaupt nicht bewusst sind. Also ich würde mir das wünschen, und wir hoffen das doch immer so, auch im Sinne der, wir klären sie mal darüber auf. Aber leider fürchte ich, dass die Menschen da sehr träge sind und sich einfach auch eine Menge bieten lassen, so wie sie es heute auch schon tun würden.
Also das ist wirklich nur ein ganz kleiner Prozentsatz, der im Endeffekt dem Händler dann nicht großartig was ausmachen wird.
Gut, innerhalb der nächsten 10 Jahre wird das sicherlich noch nicht jeder haben.
Richtig, klar.
Von daher, gut, bleibt uns erstmal Zeit, sag ich jetzt mal.
Also die haben da auch Umfragen gemacht und da kommen dann so Zahlen raus, wie 55% wollen es gerne zum Online-Einkaufen einsetzen.
Das ist ja immerhin, oder?
Das kommt natürlich darauf an, wie man die Frage stellt, aber das ist schon eine relativ große Zahl.
Aber das Forzieren von solchen biometrischen Daten, das machen ja nicht nur die Industrie, das macht ja auch die öffentliche Hand, manchmal in einer ziemlich subtilen Weise. Also ich hab da in einem Weblog, bekannte auch Kai Raven, der hat darüber berichtet, eins Live-Radio aus NRW, die haben da so einen Webbewerb gemacht, wer sieht den Moderator am ähnlichsten? Und da durfte dann der Doppelgänger gewählt werden. Oder wurde da rausgerastert irgendwie. Also von der Seite wird sowas auch schon passiert.
Na klar, und auch so die üblichen, berühmte, diese Zookarte, die biometrische, oder auch eben zum Ausleihen von Videos, das gibt es schon. Ich denke, wenn man zusammenfassen will, wenn wir nochmal zurückkommen darauf, wie eigentlich man später mit diesem elektronischen Ausweis umgehen kann, also muss einem eines bewusst sein, hier ist ein ganz hohes Informationsbedürfnis bei den Bürgern und auch ein Beratungsbedarf, also uns ist noch vollkommen unklar, wer das eigentlich leisten soll, denn es ist eigentlich heute schon so was auf dem Mädeamt, dann immer wenig Zeit ist, die ganze Prozedur dauert ja länger, und ich frage mich, wer diese Informations- und Beratungsangebote eigentlich machen soll, weil die Broschüren, die wir...
Da gibt es garantiert wieder irgendwelche Flyer, wo dann drin sind, wo sie sagen, hier lesen sie es durch, alles drin, und es versteht niemand.
Genau, und vor diesem Hintergrund fand ich also diese Regelung so zynisch, dass sie sagen, naja, ab 75 interessiert uns das nicht mehr, die verstehen das eh nicht mehr. Ich fand das eigentlich eine Frechheit. Das kann man auch nachlesen in den Bundesratsempfehlungen. Da dachte ich, na hallo, ich mach denn mal ein System, was nicht so kompliziert ist, weil eigentlich ist das nämlich nur ein Ausweis und eben keine Servicekarte für die Industrie. Das war so ein bisschen... Wenn man zusammenfassen will, ist nicht einfach zu verstehen für das Bürger.
Wir müssen ja sagen, wir haben ja prinzipiell nichts gegen solche elektronischen Identifizierung im Internet. Das Problem ist halt wirklich, die Kopplung mit dem Ausweis zu machen. Das heißt, das ist wirklich verpflichtend, beziehungsweise zu koppeln mit Dokumenten, die man auf jeden Fall besitzen muss. In der Schweiz zum Beispiel ist es so gelöst, dass man zusätzlich die Bürgercard kriegt, oder Österreich oder beide. Auf jeden Fall, wenn es zwei getrennte Karten sind, dann kann jeder das schön benutzen, wenn er lustig ist. Und kann sich auch sicher sein, dass kein anderer auf die biometrischen Daten zugreift, wenn er wirklich eine andere Karte reinsteckt. Wenn man jetzt bei sich zu Hause den Personalausweis reinsteckt, dann ist immer noch so ein Restrisiko, dass sie irgendwas falsch gemacht haben oder was auch immer, und dann wirklich über das Internet die Fingerdrücke abgefragt werden können.
Oder dass halt auch der Bürger was falsch macht, denn die Karte hat dann zwei oder drei Pins und man muss dem dann... Also ich denke nicht, dass sehr viele Leute kapieren werden, wann sie welche PIN eingeben müssen und wann sie welche PIN nicht eingeben dürfen.
Denn 99% aller Computerfehler sitzen einwiesermaßen davor. Ihr seid im Chaos Radio auf Fritz Nummer 131. Wir reden über den anstehenden elektronischen Personalausweis, den jeder von euch und von uns spätestens ab dem 1.11.2010 irgendwann bekommen wird. Es ist nämlich so beschlossen, wenn ihr Fragen dazu habt, könnt ihr uns gerne anrufen, 0331 77 97 110. Danke Sebastian. Und der nächste am Telefon ist Flo. Hallo Flo, guten Abend. Grüß dich. Möchtest du sagen, von wo du anrufst, oder unterliegt das der Geheimhaltungspflicht? Ah, klar.
Wir können uns kaum auf den Sitz halten. Bitte sag uns deinen Trick.
Moment, das weiß ja noch keiner, warum Flo anruft. Flo, warum rufst du an?
Und zwar habe ich einen kleinen Trick rausgefunden, wie man sich sehr unauffällig die Fingerabdrücke wegmachen kann.
Pauschenschuhe anziehen.
Nee, und zwar ist das mal passiert, ich im Surf auf einer Feier, so Assi-Tonne mit Feuer drin und so, kennt man ja. Autsch. Ich versuchte, die wegzuschieben. Ja, ich hab dann versucht, so eine brennende Tonne wegzuschieben.
Moment, jetzt kommt der öffentlich-rechtliche Rundfunk, sagt Sternchen, Kinder versucht das niemals zu Hause, Sternchen aus.
Genau, es hat nämlich saumäßig weh. Und es hat nur ein Sekündchen gedauert oder so, hab ich natürlich wieder losgelassen und ein paar Tage später stell ich fest, dass meine Fingerabdrücke ziemlich glatt sind.
Alles weg.
Diese Methode möchte ich dich jetzt unbedingt empfehlen.
Das ist nicht wirklich, ja, aber...
Ich mein, man kann mal auf die Herdplatte fassen und so, aber...
Nee, kann man nicht.
Man kann sich die Hand auch abpacken, dann sind sie auch weg.
Bist du doof und probierst das nochmal wirklich und es funktioniert auch auf der Herdplatte.
Was hast du denn...
Genau eine Sekunde.
Es geht mich jetzt wirklich nichts an, aber hast du irgendwie eine masochistische Ader, dass du gerne Schmerzen hast oder so?
Vor allen Dingen hast du das Problem, dass du das da mit allen Fingern machen wollen müsstest. Denn wenn sie Fingerabdrücke dir für den elektronischen Pass abnehmen und dann wahrscheinlich auch für den Personalausweis, dann probieren sie erstmal die Zeigefinger und wenn die nicht gehen, probieren sie die anderen Finger durch, sodass sie insgesamt alle acht Finger probiert haben, denn die kleinen Finger zählen nicht. Warum nicht? Weil da ist nicht genug drauf. Und wenn dann von allen Fingern keiner brauchbar ist, dann nehmen sie den, der noch am wenigsten unbrauchbar ist.
Ach so, also mit dem Daumen, das wird ein bisschen schwierig gleichzeitig draufzupacken.
Das verhindert einen auch im normalen Leben, man kann ja nicht mehr tippen und so.
Das ist nicht richtig verbrannt, das war wirklich nur die oberste Hautschicht.
Flo, ich glaube ich möchte gar keine Details hören oder da kriegt der Kicker einen Herpesweck dazu. Lange Rede, kurzer Sinn, die Idee ist angekommen, ist aber wegen Unpraktikabilität und allgemeiner wenig Durchsetzbarkeit wieder abgelenkt.
Die hockt schon, oder?
Also ich würde das durchziehen, warte mal.
Ich meine natürlich, also man kann das physisch zerstören. Man muss aber auch bedenken, dass natürlich so ist, dass der Mensch sich natürlich diese Minuzien wieder zurückbitt. Also nach einer Weile ist er einfach wieder da.
Aber andererseits, wir haben ja am Anfang der Sendung auch festgestellt, dass die Abgabe der Fingerabdrücke für den elektronischen Ausweis freiwillig ist. Ich kann ja sagen, möchte ich nicht. Ja, noch. Dann läuft der Ausweis zehn Jahre, dann kann man es später weiter sehen. Also man muss nicht zu so rabiaten Mitteln greifen wie Flo. Der eigentliche Punkt, der ja viel interessanter und viel spannender ist, ist das mit der elektronischen Signatur, was wir gerade angesprochen haben. Das müssen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen genauer erläutern. Also, wir konstruieren immer eine Situation. Ich sitze an meinem Rechner und kaufe online irgendwas ein. Oder schließe einen Vertrag ab, irgendeine Versicherung kann man ja auch online machen. Die wollen von mir jetzt eine Bestätigung, dass ich wirklich ich bin. Früher gab es einfach nur, haben die mir ein Papier geschickt, ich hab's unterschrieben, das haben die wieder zurückgeschickt, damit war's klar. Das soll jetzt anders laufen, nämlich wie?
Na, elektronische Signatur tatsächlich nur zum Vertragsabschließen. Das gibt es auch jetzt schon, das gibt es schon Ewigkeiten, das benutzt bloß keiner.
Genau.
Also halt nicht auf den Personalausweis, sondern halt als separate Karte.
Also wo wir uns eigentlich haben wollten. Gibt es als separate Karte, mit einem Trastzentrum muss man dann dahin gehen, kann sich eine Karte kaufen und eine elektronische Signatur dazu. Das kostet dann halt pro Jahr x Euro. Gar nicht mal so wenig, glaub ich sogar.
Ich glaub 80 oder 90, ne?
Also so viel war, würd ich jetzt nicht sagen. Also bei einer Sparkasse machen das zum Beispiel, kannst du es dann, glaub ich, sogar gleich auf die Sparkassenkarte tun, wenn du das willst.
Du kannst in Zukunft auch auf die elektronische Gesundheitskarte drauf machen.
Auf die elektronische Gesundheitskarte.
Oder auf die allgemeine Steuer... Ne, gut, Steuerlohn was? Auch noch ein anderes Thema. Ne, wir bleiben jetzt mal bei dieser elektronischen... Bei dieser elektronischen Identifikation. EID, genau. Das müssen wir noch mal genauer erklären. Weil das gibt's schon, aber das soll jetzt mit dem Ausweis gekoppelt werden.
Das kann mit dem Ausweis gekoppelt werden. Sie denken sich dann halt, also es gibt es schon seit, ich weiß nicht, fünf Jahren, benutzt keiner. Wenn wir jetzt jedem sowieso einen Personalausweis in die Hand drücken, dann tun wir doch gleich einfach mal die Möglichkeit vorsehen, sodass man das mit dem Personalausweis machen kann.
Und wo ist jetzt der Punkt, an dem ihr sagt, böse böse?
Er ist halt wieder gekoppelt, also will man nicht wirklich.
Das sind mehrere Punkte. Eine, was wir eben schon erwähnt haben, das ist relativ schwierig zu handhaben dann für den User, vor allen Dingen sicher. Und es ist tatsächlich auch so, dass sie jetzt gesagt haben, die Sicherheitsproblematik wird auf den User ausgelagert. Also er muss sich darum kümmern, dass seine Geheimnummer eben niemand rauskommt.
Also mal kurz zur Handhabung. Ich hab mal so eine Demonstration gesehen bei so einem Vortrag. Und die gute Frau, also die war von der Bundesdokerei und war auf jeden Fall selbst echt überfordert. Ich meine, sie hat diesen Vortrag gehalten, sie hat das vorgeführt und also sie müsste dreimal eine PIN eingeben, musste dann irgendwie Ewigkeiten rumklicken, welche Daten sie jetzt übertragen wollte und welche nicht. Und das hab selbst ich nicht mehr wirklich verstanden, was sie vorne getan hat. Und ich kann vor mir sagen, dass ich mir mit Technik gar nichts auskenne. In der Form, wie sie es vorgeführt hat, würde es keiner benutzen können.
Also die größte Gefahr, die besteht, ist, dass Daten an Leute übertragen werden, die diese Daten eigentlich einfach nicht angehen.
Genau, also das ist das auf jeden Fall.
Das oder das man überhaupt generell scheiterte zu benutzen. Aber darüber hinaus, habe ich noch mal darüber nachgedacht, warum muss dieses hoheitliche Dokument denn plötzlich so eine Servicefunktion enthalten, die wir natürlich auch bezahlen müssen. Und wo auch klar ist, dass die Kosten direkt umgelegt werden. Denn die Kommunen haben sich verbeten, dass sie nochmals Teile dieser Kosten tragen, wie es schon beim Reisepass. Also wir werden das alle bezahlen. Wofür? Also es gibt keine gute Begründung, außer eben wieder mal industriepolitische Förderung. Und ich denke, das ist kein guter Grund. Es gibt ja einige Nachteile dafür, wofür dieses Dokument eigentlich gemacht ist. Nämlich etwa, um sich ausweisen zu können bei einer Polizeikontrolle. Denn wir haben ja noch nicht erwähnt, dass es jetzt ein Scheckkartenformat ist. Das heißt, die Polizisten kriegen eine Lupe, damit sie das Bild überhaupt lesen können. Das ist ja viel kleiner. Das heißt, für die eigentlichen Behörden ist die Benutzung weit schlechter.
Also genauso wie auch schon beim elektronischen Reisepass, das Frontalfoto, was halt der Person, also der Menschen, der dahinter sitzt, der früher im Halbprofilbild das Ohr gesehen hat, was halt sehr wichtig war für die manuelle Überprüfung, ob die Person übereinstimmt. Diese Möglichkeit gibt es jetzt nicht mehr. Da hat man nur das Frontalfoto, sieht die Ohren nicht mehr. Und hat deswegen viel mehr Schwierigkeiten, überhaupt die Person zu identifizieren.
Naja, und wenn er keine Lupe hat. Das sind eher so diese Metergrunde, die wir sehen. Also dazu kommt natürlich auch noch ein Bedrohungspotenzial, das es früher nicht gab. Nämlich da geht es um die Frage der automatisierten Speicherung, des automatisierten Abgleiches. Denn auch das ist alles schon vorgesehen. Das heißt, eine ganze Latte von Behörden haben dann natürlich sofort gesagt, wir bitte auch. Also das fängt an natürlich bei den Ermittlungsbehörden, aber auch der Bundesnachrichtendienste, Militärische Abschirmdienste, die Verfassungsschutzämter. Alle haben gesagt, wir wollen auch bitte bei dem automatisierten Abgleich mitmachen.
Das heißt, wenn irgendwo mein Ausweis gecheckt wird, wird er nicht nur an einer Stelle überprüft, im Einwohner-Meldeamt, sondern gleich mal bei allen möglichen Stellen.
Das ist natürlich sehr unterschiedlich geregelt, aber auf jeden Fall sollten Abgleich geben mit allen Personen, Auskunftsdateien, die die Sicherheitsbehörden so haben. Und es ist vor allen Dingen vorgeschlagen worden, dass man gleich einen 1 zu N-Abgleich macht. Was ist so ein 1 zu N-Abgleich? Man soll über die Datenbanken vergleichen. Es gibt ja etwa in Deutschland die ARVS-Datenbank. Da sind jetzt etwa 4 Millionen Fingerabdrücke gespeichert. Und dann könnte man sich vorstellen, dass sogar mobil, also etwa ein Einsatzfahrzeug, gegen diese Datenbank gecheckt wird. Weil sie ja wissen, dass man Ausweisdokumente auch kaufen kann. Das ist nun mal so. Und bei einem 1 zu 1-Abgleich, also wenn man eben seinen Finger da auf den Scanner legt, nicht so wirklich sagen kann, ob das wirklich auch vielleicht nicht ein Dokument ist, was falsche Werte enthält, haben sie sich überlegt, na, machen wir eben 1 zu n. Das war alles ursprünglich nicht vorgesehen. Das ist halt auch so ein weiterer Schritt in den, ja, viel zitierten Überwachungsstaat. Das wurde dann also so hin und rum mit eingeführt.
Wie ist es mit der Sicherheit dieser ganzen Daten und Datenbanken? Wir hatten in der letzten Zeit in Deutschland immer wieder Fälle von Datenhandel und von Daten, die gekauft werden können und so. Das bedeutet doch jetzt, wenn dieser elektronische Ausweis kommt, dass es noch eine neue Datenbank gibt mit noch mehr Parametern, die von mir gespeichert werden, die auf irgendeinem Server liegen. Und früher oder später wird auch dieses Ding geknackt werden. Das hat sich ja die Vergangenheit auch gezeigt.
Ja, also vor allem halt sehr, sehr brisante Daten auch. Also es geht hier halt wirklich um ureigenste persönliche Daten, wie halt zum Beispiel die Fingerabdrücke. Und halt wo heutzutage Kreditkartendaten irgendwie im Internet verkauft werden, gekauft werden können oder halt irgendwie Kontodaten wird auf jeden Fall in den nächsten Jahren, wenn es erstmal die Daten gibt, auch Fingerabdrücke natürlich verkauft werden. Also halt, wenn man diese Fingerabdrücke zum Beispiel zum Einkaufen oder zum Auslenden in der Videothek benutzen kann, dann werden natürlich auch Leute auf die Idee kommen, die Daten halt irgendwie für viel Geld zu verkaufen.
Ja, da sind halt so natürlich jetzt andere Gefahren als nur die im Geschäftsverkehr, wenn ich mir halt in irgendeinem Online-Händler da was klicke, aber die Gefahren sind einfach schlicht da.
Oder am Ort des Verbrechens zu hinterlassen, das geht natürlich auch. Also es wird halt schon seit Jahr und Tag gemacht. Allerdings hat man jetzt halt viel mehr Möglichkeiten, ganz einfach auf Daten von Leuten zuzugreffen. Das heißt, man kann da sich einfach mal ein Set von 10 Fingerabdrucker-Trappen nehmen und halt irgendwie Lieschen Müller des Mordes irgendwie verdächtigen lassen.
Wird es denn, das Hauptargument für den elektronischen Ausweis ist ja, das Ding ist sicherer und es ist einfacher zu handeln und es ist alles toller, besser und schöner. Gesetzt den Fall, mir kommt der Ausweis von Starbuck in die Finger und ich gehe jetzt damit irgendwie einkaufen, was auch immer, kann ich mich als Starbuck ausgeben? Weil laut diesem Ausweis, wenn ich das irgendwie online mache, ist ja nicht klar, dass ich's bin.
Also sicherer wird der sicherlich nicht, da wie gesagt immer noch gültig ist, wenn der Chip kaputt ist. Online ausweisen wird, wenn du den Ausweis einfach so findest, wahrscheinlich nicht gehen, weil man da immerzu immer noch eine PIN braucht. Es sei denn natürlich, Starbucks schreibt die PIN auf den Ausweis, wie sie wahrscheinlich sehr flippe über tun werden. Denn eine PIN ist ja schon aufgedruckt. Es hat, das haben wir vielleicht noch nicht erwähnt, es hat zwei oder drei PINs. Zum einen eine, die nur zum Aufbau der verschiedenen Verbindungen gedacht ist. Dann eine PIN, die für diese Authentisierungsfunktion gedacht ist, also dieses Weitergeben an einen Online-Dienst. Und dann gegebenenfalls noch eine dritte PIN für die elektronische Signatur.
Das heißt, ich muss mir noch drei weitere PINs nacken.
Genau, eine ist aufgedruckt, aber zwei. Ein oder zwei PINs merken. Und dann natürlich noch dazu merken, wann man welche PIN eingeben darf und wann man sie nicht eingeben darf vor allen Dingen.
Herzlichen Glückwunsch, damit ist es übrigens 23 Uhr. Letzter Mittwoch im Monat, damit Zeit für das Chaos Radio mit dem Chaos Computer Club auf Fritz, Konz, Starbuck und Henrik sind bei uns. Wir reden über den elektronischen Personalausweis, der ab dem 1.11.2010 eingeführt wird und der früher oder später auch an euch in irgendeiner Form vorbeigehen wird und ihr habt dann die Freude oder aber das Problem, euch mit diesem zu beschäftigen. Wir versuchen heute, die verschiedenen Aspekte des elektronischen Ausweises zu beleuchten. Gehen wir gerne auch mit euch unter der 0331 70 97 110. Wir haben jetzt viele kritische Sachen zu diesem Ausweis besprochen. Es gibt aber auch positive Aspekte dazu und deswegen hat uns Simon angerufen. Hallo Simon, guten Abend. Grüße dich. Du bist gar nicht so Kontra-Ausweis.
Jein, ich bin kontra die aktuelle Implementation. Aber im Prinzip könnte man es bei der Gelegenheit quasi richtig machen. Die Idee ist jetzt die, im Prinzip ein Ausweisdokument ist ja etwas, was mir die Bundesregierung gibt und was ich dann sozusagen den Bediensteten der Bundesregierung zurückgeben kann und das soll mir möglichst fälschungssicher sein. Das ist die grundsätzliche Idee dahinter. Und sowas haben wir ja kryptografisch gesehen, nämlich Zertifikate. Und die Idee wäre jetzt, im Prinzip kann ich auf jeder beliebigen RSA-Kryptokarte, die es ja für 20 Euro irgendwo zu kaufen gibt, kann ich mir im Prinzip einen vernünftigen fälschungs-sicheren Ausweis daraus bauen. Ich hol mir sozusagen meine Karte von irgendwo her, lasse mir die persönlich bedrucken, wie es mir gerade lustig ist, generiere mir einen Schlüssel und gehe sozusagen auf ein Wohnermeldeamt und lasse mir von denen ein Zertifikat geben, dass das ich bin. Auf die Weise könnte man die Bundesdrückerei komplett rauslassen aus der gesamten Ausweisgeschichte.
Sie müsste man auch herstellen. Warum willst du sie rausnehmen? Der Staat übergibt dir das Dokument praktisch. Er will natürlich auch, dass es da eine Stelle gibt, die da dann auch noch Geld verdient, bzw. die diese hoheitlichen Aufgaben übernimmt. Der Pass selber oder der Ausweis ist ja nicht nur die Signatur, sondern es ist natürlich auch ein optisches Merkmal mit Sicherheitsfeatures drauf. Also da sind inzwischen so viele Sachen, dass man das nicht auf ein Zertifikat runterbrechen kann.
Und was wir an der Stelle sehen?
Der Punkt ist, dass ich im Prinzip, könnte man einfach auch sagen, diese optischen Sicherheitsfeatures, die sind eh nicht mehr zeitgemäß, weil das würde dir sowieso nicht gefällt.
Na ja, also die Streifenpolizisten, die existiert schon, auch wenn man sie nicht mehr so häufig sieht.
Also zum Thema Fälschen, also der deutsche Reisepass ist halt immer noch das sicherste Reisendokument auf der Welt. Das heißt, die haben so viel Sachen drauf, um jetzt zu behaupten, das kann man ganz einfach fälschen. Das ist auf jeden Fall irgendwie nicht richtig.
Was man machen kann, ist es schlicht kaufen. Also das ist ja nur schon seit Längerem bekannt. Es gab halt diese ziemlich bekannte Doku der BBC, wo sie mal einen Journalisten losgeschickt haben und die hat tatsächlich aus 20 europäischen Ländern Ausweisdokumente gekauft. Das war so ein Preis zwischen 150 und 1500 Pfund. Also in Deutschland oder in Frankreich war es teurer als etwa in Slowenien oder in der Slowakei. Aber die Gefahr ist ja nicht die Fälschung des physischen Dokuments. Weil das ist halt einfach zu schwer und zu teuer. Sondern man bestichtert einfach jemanden, das ist Usus. Und nicht etwa, dass man sich hinstellt und zu Hause in seiner Fälscher Werkstatt da anfängt zu kopieren.
Mit Blaupause und Bleistift und Papier und irgendwelche Dinge zu machen. Was wir übrigens vorhin, da gab es noch einen Einwand, den wir dringend noch korrigieren müssen. Der Preis für den elektronischen Reisepass von 60 Euro, da wird natürlich nicht von der Bundesdruckerei festgestellt, festgelegt, sondern vom Ministerium. Richtig, klar. Nicht, dass die Bund das sagt. Okay, das musste nur noch kurz geklärt werden.
Ja und dieser RSA-Kartenplan ist natürlich auch aus anderen Gründen unausgereift. Dieses Zertifikat ist auf der Karte schon drauf, allerdings verwenden sie nicht unbedingt RSA, sondern sie machen da ECC zum Beispiel. Du hast das Problem, dass du gegebenenfalls nicht in der Lage bist, einen sicheren Schlüssel zu generieren. Das ist nämlich alles, wird dann von der Bundesdruckerei in ordentlich zertifizierten Umgebungen gemacht, während wenn du selber zu Hause einen Schlüssel generierst, wenn du eine Debian-Kiste hast, naja.
So den will ich auf der Karte generieren.
Ja, ansonsten, wenn du ihn auf der Karte generierst, das machen sie nämlich extra nicht bei diesem professionellen, kommerziellen System, weil sie dem Zufallzeilen-Generator auf der Karte nicht so sehr vertrauen, dass er nicht vielleicht doch irgendwann mal was falsch macht.
Jemand muss jetzt mal Hendrik stoppen, sonst sieht er nicht mehr aus.
Und selbst wenn du ihn extern generierst, selbst wenn du ihn, du kannst ihn auch selber erzeugen und dann kannst du, also ein Bekannter von mir hat sich zum Beispiel einen Schlüssel, einen RSA-Schlüssel erzeugen lassen, wo eine der beiden Primzahlen drei war. Und den dann offiziell signieren lassen. Von daher, das ist auch ein interessanter Faktor.
Warte mal, Gentlemen, kurzer Einwurf. Das führt jetzt sehr, sehr, sehr ins technische Detail. Simon, ich würde vorschlagen, wenn dich das mir noch mehr interessiert mit der Generierung dieser Schlüssel auf der Karte, dann einfach eine Mail schreiben an Chaosradio, die CDU und Henrik und du, ihr könnt euch dann stundenlange Mails hin- und herschicken.
Und er meint es so stundenlang.
Nee, weil ohne Quatsch, ich bin jetzt ausgestiegen. Ich verstehe kein Wort mehr. Ja, also wenn ihr beiden Hardware-Nerds könntet das vielleicht dann irgendwie untereinander klären oder weitere Fragen dann dazu machen, weil wir wollen eigentlich zurück zum elektronischen Ausweis. Und Ben hat uns angerufen. Hallo, Ben grüßt dich. Es ist kurz vor zwölf. Dein Beitrag.
Ähm, ich hätte eine Frage. Ihr habt ja gerade gesagt, dass der Perso dann bald so aussehen wird, wie eine ganz normale Geldkarte.
Wie sieht ein Kartenformat ja?
Ja, wie eine EC-Karte so. Wird der dann noch mal irgendwie verstärkt werden?
Oder wird der...
Ist der dann genauso stabil, wie diese ganzen schönen EC-Karten?
Nee, nee, das ist eine richtige Plastikkarte.
Also, er ist genauso stabil, das ist halt eine... Genau, also so genannte ID.1-Karten. Die haben halt definierte Dimensionen, auch eine definierte Dicke und definiertes Material. Das heißt, die werden halt genau die gleiche Stabilität haben, wie auch für die Karte.
ISO 7810, glaube ich, war das.
Also, das heißt dann im Endeffekt, dass man innerhalb von drei Monaten, wenn man sich irgendwie mal ungünstig draufsetzt, dann eben schnell das Perso-Teil erstmal durchbricht.
Das kann durchaus passieren.
Und man dann wahrscheinlich einfach mal 60 Euro wieder rausschmeißen darf.
Auch das wird dann sehr wahrscheinlich der Fall sein.
Ja, das ist ja in dem Fall dann dein Problem, wenn du es irgendwie kaputt aufgesetzt. Wenn du dich aufsetzt.
Wenn man etwa diese Karte, die man heute hat, wenn man die verbrennt oder auf den Herd legt, um mal auf unseren vorherigen Anruf zurückzukommen, dann muss man natürlich auch seine eigenen Kosten tragen, wenn man den neuen dann mal antragt.
Wenn du deinen Blumentopf aus dem Fenster schmeißt, musst du ja auch einen neuen kaufen.
Das ist schon was anderes, wenn man zum Beispiel auf die elektronischen Daten drauf angewiesen ist. Das heißt, es muss ja nicht in der Mitte durchknacken, sondern es reicht, dass der Chip nicht mehr mit der Antenne verbunden ist. Das heißt, diese ganzen Zusatzfunktionen, für die wir viel Geld bezahlt haben, elektronische Unterschrift, EID, die dann nicht mehr nutzbar sind, und wer dann dafür haftet, wenn es kaputt ist, weil es ist ja eigentlich ein Herstellerfehler, dann müssten eigentlich schon andere Regeln gelten.
Das wird auch nochmal total spannend, denn eine der interessanten Zusatzfunktionen, die sie sich da so ausgedacht haben, ist, dass man es zum Beispiel in der Firma als Zutrittskontrollsystem verwenden kann. Wenn sie dann kaputt geht, dann werden wir sicherlich noch sehr viele spaßige Geschichten zu erzählen haben.
Na, da ist noch so ein Detail, was wir vielleicht auch nochmal erwähnen sollten. Man kann die besprochenen Funktionen aktivieren und deaktivieren.
Kann ich das selber machen?
Nein, wenn ich im Inland den Personalausweis beantrage, dann sage ich, ob ich es möchte. Dann wird der Hersteller mir das aktivieren.
Also ob du Fingerabdrücke drauf haben möchtest, ob du elektronische Signaturen und EID drauf haben willst.
EID aktivierst du aber bei der Ausgabe, nicht beim Hersteller.
Das ist unterschiedlich. Da unterscheiden sie zwischen inländischen und ausländischen Passantragsbehörden. Da wird es noch unterschiedliche Verfahren geben. Das ist sehr interessant. Auf jeden Fall aber müssen die Meldbehörden irgendein Gerät haben, mit dem sie diese Funktionen an- und abschalten. Das ist natürlich auch ein Sicherheitsproblem, weil es sind Tausende Behörden in gesamten Bundesgebieten und außerhalb der Bundesrepublik.
Der Punkt ist, man kann jederzeit, wenn man sich bei der Ausgabe entschieden hat, wenn man keine Fingerdrücke drauf hat, keine Signaturen usw. kann man jederzeit wieder zu Meldbeamten gehen und sagen, ich möchte es jetzt doch, aber ich hab's mir anders überlegt. Das heißt, der Chip ist zumindest für alle Meldbeamten in den 6000 Meldestellen plus Auslandsvertretung plus was weiß ich, wenn auch alles, hat Schreibrechte auf diesem Chip. Und das ist das richtig große Problem, was sie noch gar nicht angesprochen haben.
Gibt's für einen Reisepass natürlich nicht. Das ist hier also ein neues Unsicherheitsmerkmal.
Das ist halt irgendwie nix, was man mal, ja, es ist nicht so schlimm, da kann man drüber hinwegsehen. Das sind wirklich eklatante Sicherheitsprobleme und es ist mir total rätselhaft, wie sie auf die Idee gekommen sind, dass sie das überhaupt machen. Ich hab mich mit Politikern darüber unterhalten. Da hab ich gesagt, dass sie da beim Reisepass kann man immer sagen, okay, das ist zwar unsicher, aber das sind alles theoretische Angriffsmöglichkeiten. Aber hier haben sie sich so ein riesengroßes Scheuenloch eingebaut, dass es mir wirklich total unklar wäre, auf diese bescheuerte Idee gekommen ist.
Also als wir das Grobkonzept zuerst gesehen haben, da haben wir erstmal nur den Köpfen geschüttet. Also das ist ja auch nicht so, dass unser, gerade das Innenministerium, nicht kompetenter Fachleute hätte. Gerade im BSI, also im Bundesamt für Sicherheit, für die Informationstechnik, sind seit Jahren da Expertise. Denn das ist ja dieselbe Gruppe, die auch bei Preise passt, die technische Spezifikationen, die macht es mir also schleierhaft, wie sie auf die Idee kommt.
Also zum Thema, was du vorhin meintest, du findest meinen Ausweis und du hast natürlich meine PIN nicht, aber du kannst dir halt, irgendein Freund, der im Melleamt arbeitet, und das sind halt wirklich 10.000 in Deutschland, kannst du hingehen und sagen, wie setzt doch mal bitte die PIN irgendwie wieder neu, weil ich möchte jetzt irgendwie für Starbucks einkaufen gehen. Das würde gehen.
Denn wir wissen natürlich, dass Menschen Menschen sind und ihre Geheimnummern vergessen. Also das ist natürlich bekannt. Es wird nicht so selten sein, wenn Tausende Fälle sein. Denn du sind nur mal Leute, das kann man bei den Banken erfragen. Da vergessen die Leute ja auch dauernd ihre PINs. Das ist nun mal so. Menschen sind halt keine Roboter.
Und wenn du die PIN für den elektronischen Identitätsnachweis hast, dann kannst du online ein qualifiziertes elektronisches Signaturzertifikat beantragen, ohne noch mal irgendwo auftauchen zu müssen. Und hast dann eine ordentliche rechtsgültige Signatur, die identisch zur eigenhändigen Unterschrift ist, im Namen von Star Wars.
Also das ist wirklich die Katastrophe schlechthin überhaupt.
Wir haben da übrigens auch noch Benne am Telefon. Durch das du denkst, wir haben dich vergessen.
Bennes Frage war, glaube ich, hauptsächlich darauf gezielt, was passiert, wenn ich mich da draufsetze wie mit meinem Führerschein.
Und ich habe noch eine Vermutung, wie dann bald die Polizisten aussehen werden. Ich vergleiche die jetzt so langsam mit Kontrolleuren in der Bahn, dass die mit so einem Bläsegerät sich hinterher so nehmen und dadurch das Bild so vergrößert wird.
Im Zweifelsfall würde ich jetzt nur vermuten, hat der Polizeibeamte an sich da auch nicht großen Spaß dran, weil er kann doch ein weiteres Gerät mit sich rumschleppen und muss irgendwas von sich am Gürtel gehängt haben. Aber das ist ein anderes Thema. Danke dir, Benne.
Tschüss. Das Gerät ist natürlich auch irgendwie nicht so klein, weil da muss da ein Fingerabdrucksensor drin sein.
Über diese ganzen Dinge möchte ich jetzt gerne kurz 5 Minuten nachdenken. Hier ist Bugs.
Die National Security Agency überwacht die ganze Welt.
Faxgeräte, Telefone, Satellitenkommunikation. Sie sind die einzigen im Land einschließlich des Militärs, die über solche Geräte verfügen.
Die haben sie geortet.
Sie senden immer noch ein Signal aus ihrem Kragen, Gürtel oder Schlips. Schmeißen sie ihre Klamotten weg. Wenn sie morgen noch leben, bin ich tief beeindruckt.
Aus Hannover über Wachungsstaat von der Kriegstaggebuch Maxi. Ihr hört das Chaos Radio auf Fritz. Es ist Viertel 12, Nummer 139 sind wir. Und wir reden über den anstehenden elektronischen Personalausweis, der ab 1. November 2010 dann eingeführt wird. Wir waren auch schon beim elektronischen Reisepass quasi. Der kleine Vorläufer und Testballon für das, was dann später der Ausweis werden wird. Der kostet im Moment 60 Euro. Allerdings nicht für Micha, der hat mehr bezahlt. Hallo Micha.
Guten Abend. Also, ich hatte einen Job-Aniveau, den ich in Florida für 10 Tage hatte. Und da musste ich meinen Bürgeramt schnell mir einen Reisepass machen lassen. E-Pass. Für den USA soll E-Pass sein.
Schon mit Fingerabdrucken oder nur Geschichtsmit?
Ja, alles mit Fingerabdruck und biometrisches Foto.
Oha, erzähl mal.
Naja, 91 Euro.
Nicht den Preis, erzähl mal erstmal die Prozedur.
Naja, Finger offen, also alle fünf Finger mussten, also nicht, also keine Finger musste auch mit drauf.
Was?
Dann haben die wieder nicht richtig gelesen, okay.
Warum haben sie deine Finger, also warum haben sie überhaupt mehr als ein Anzeigefinger abgenommen? Also war die Qualität zu schlecht oder was?
Nee, die machen die generell.
Nee.
Okay, also beschreib mal, du kommst dahin und dann haben sie dir den Fingerabdruckscanner vor die Nase gesetzt und dann haben sie das bitte einmal auflegen, ja?
Das bitte einmal auflegen und das gleich, das hat, das Ding scannt ja glaube ich drei Mal durch pro Finger. Das hat eine ganze Weile gedauert.
Das heißt, du hast da 30 Mal deine Finger auflegen müssen?
Deswegen dauert es so lange.
Na ja, das ist nicht unbedingt so vorgesehen. Wenn du das so machen kannst, kannst du ja als Bürger nicht wissen, wie lange hat das etwa gedauert, bis du dann endlich mal die Fingerabdrücke alle ausgelesen hatten?
Also, wissen wir, das war eine Weile, ja, weil das hat bestimmt eine Viertelstunde gedauert oder so, alles.
Boah, aber dann will ich mal den Ausweis auslesen. Also, ich meine, wenn die halt wirklich alle abgenommen haben und alle in dem Pass gespeichert sind, kommst du aus Berlin?
Dann könntest du uns hier mal besuchen.
Genau, schreib uns doch mal eine Mail. Also, das ist echt kurios, weil es sollte eigentlich nicht so sein und wenn dem so ist, dann wollen wir auf jeden Fall mal sehen, was auf dem Pass dann wirklich gespeichert ist.
Die Frage wäre ja auch jetzt gewesen, wie sieht das aus für Arbeitslose, wenn die jetzt ein Jobangebot haben?
Weil du so viel bezahlt hast, meinst du?
Wir zahlten den.
Du selber? Achso, vielleicht noch mal zum Hinweis, du hast 91 Euro statt 59 bezahlt, weil das halt ein Expresspass ist. Also du hast dann gesagt, du brauchst den halt irgendwie sofort und deswegen bezahlt man halt diesen Aufpreis von 90 Euro.
Aber was ist denn, wenn er jetzt dieses Jahr oder nächstes Jahr soll er ja irgendwie Standard werden? Wir zahlten den dann.
Wieso nicht?
Der Personalausweis wird ja auch nicht von mir aus bezahlt. Jeder, der irgendwie von Jobcenter oder von Arbeitsamt Geld bekommt, der kann zum Bürgeramt gehen und kriegt ihn umsonst. Und wenn ich den verlieren soll, dann...
Das ist eine Frage, die du dann glaube ich direkt mit deinem Berater beim Arbeitsamt erklären musst.
Wir wissen das auch wirklich nicht.
Also das war mir auch total neu, dass du die nicht selber bezahlst.
Also normalerweise ist es ja so, dass der Ausweis ein Dokument ist, den du als Bürger haben musst, egal ob jetzt Pass oder aber Ausweis, eins von beiden musst du ja haben und da bist du dann verpflichtet, dir das Ding auch zu besorgen. Aber das müsstest du echt mal mit den zuständigen Leuten bei deinem Amt besprechen, wie das dann bei dem Ausweis sein wird. Ich würde jetzt ganz ins Blaue und ohne das genaue Wissen, genau zu wissen, würde vermuten, dass die in so einem Fall die Kosten natürlich auch übernehmen. Es sei denn, es ist wie in deinem Fall jetzt ein Expresspass, der schneller gehen muss und der ist natürlich teurer. Aber da sind wir glaube ich nicht die Experten.
Aber wobei, das ist vielleicht nochmal eine Sache, die wir erwähnen sollten. Wir nehmen den Paß und den Personalausweis, es ist auch noch ein drittes Projekt gestartet. Nämlich, es gibt jetzt auch die elektronische Aufenthaltskarte. Damit haben sie auch tatsächlich die gesamte Bevölkerung erfasst.
Was ist eine?
Wenn Sie zu sagen, auch so lange hier sind, dann kriegen Sie so eine Aufenthaltskarte. Also wenn Sie eben zum Beispiel hier arbeiten und für zwei, fünf oder zehn Jahre eben eine Aufenthaltsgenehmigung haben, dann kriegen Sie auch so eine Karte. Das heißt, die werden auch biometrisch erfasst. Damit haben Sie echt so die Gesamtbevölkerung.
Das heißt, alle Leute, die innerhalb der Grenze sind, die hast du irgendwie erfasst?
Also bei Asylbewerbungen haben sie ja schon ganz zum Anfang. Also Asylbewerbungen waren praktisch so die ersten Testläufer, die alle Fingerabdrücke abgeben mussten, Gesichtsbilder und so weiter. Dann haben sie jetzt halt die normalen Leute und natürlich auch die Langzeitausländer, die hier wohnen.
Okay, Michael, ich hoffe, wir haben deine Frage jetzt zwar nicht beantwortet, aber vielleicht einen Hinweis gegeben, wo du dich nachhin wenden kannst.
Mal kurz eine zweite Frage. Macht ihr heute nur mit Sicherheit und mit Fingerabdrücken so ein bisschen Wirt?
Eigentlich ist Biometrie und der Personalausweis unser Thema. Wieso?
Na, weil ein Bekannter von mir, der hat letztens einen Vaterschaftstest machen müssen mit Lichtbild und Fingerabdruck.
Wie, er musste sein biometrisches Bild abgeben?
Nee, ein biometrisches Bild nicht. Das war ein ganz normales Foto, wurde von ihm geschossen und ein Fingerabdruck wurde genommen.
Als Vaterschaftstest.
Als Vaterschaftstest oder als Beweis dafür, dass er er ist? Nee, das hat er noch die DNA abgegeben.
Also denke mal, dafür hat derjenige auch sein Personalausweis, aber trotzdem musste er ein Fingerabdruck und ein Lichtbild abgeben.
Wo war das?
In Berlin.
Nee, welches, also Krankenhaus, oder?
Kinderarzt.
Aber die haben ja noch kein Fingerabdrucksensor beim Arzt.
Nee, das war auch nicht mit dem Scanner, wie man meint, sondern mit Tinte.
Im Zweifelsfall auch mal beim Arzt fragen, warum die das machen, dann müsste der Arzt ja auch die Tinte drücken.
Ich hab noch keinen Arzt gesehen, der einen Stempelkissen hat.
Kann ich dir genauer sagen, und zwar hat er da irgendwie mit einem Darkshots-Beauftragten in Sachsen telefoniert. Die wollten jetzt erstmal ja eine Globen, die wollten dann alle Schriftdokumente haben. Aber laut Robert-Koch-Institut soll es irgendwie dahergehen, weil er kann ja jenen hinschicken.
Ja, aber was wollen Sie dann mit einem Stempelkissen-Fingerabdruck?
Also ich mein, dafür hat er seinen Ausweis dabei, um halt zu zeigen, also seine Identität darzustellen. Das ist halt irgendwie genau dafür, wo der Ausweis für da ist.
Okay, wir sind aber heute eher bei der elektronischen Variante und nicht bei der Tintenvariante. Aber Micha, wenn du da irgendwie noch mehr Infos brauchst, einfach mal Mail schicken an Chaosradio.rccc.de. Vielleicht kann man das irgendwie noch weiterleiten. 0331 70 97 110 ist die Telefonnummer vom Chaosradio. Auf Fritz der Nächste am Telefon ist Sophia oder Sophias? Sophias. Ein griechischer oder bulgarischer Name?
Das ist eine Variante von Sophia plus auf Lojban. Also mein Problem, was ich ein bisschen mit der ganzen Frage, allgemein Pässe und Datenschutz und so habe, ist, dass es immer so letztendlich, also ich frag mich, inwiefern es unbedingt legitim ist, dass der Staat im Prinzip jeder Informationen mehr oder weniger bekommen kann, die er letztendlich haben will, weil...
Ach so, also dass du dich sozusagen damit abfinden musst, dass der Staat sagt, ich hätte gerne von dir die und die und die und die Daten und du kannst nicht sagen, nein will ich nicht.
Ich meine, es gibt die Meldeamter und da weißt du ja schon mal, auch ohne Biometrie und alles, wo ich wohne, wie ich heiße und überhaupt und...
Ja, die Biometrie ist jetzt auch quasi nur noch das Sahnehäubchen oben drauf und derzeit ist es so, dass sie sich nicht mal Mühe gegeben haben, irgendwie zu begründen, warum jetzt die Biometrie auch in diesen Personalausweis kommt. Bei dem Reisepass haben sie ja immer noch von Sicherheit und so gelabert, was man natürlich auch an da fragen kann, aber beim Personalausweis haben sie nicht mehr eine richtige Begründung dafür. Und durch die Hintertür wird mit diesem neuen Personalausweisgesetz ja auch noch eben das Online-Abrufverfahren, dass man eben auch online auf diese Daten zugreifen kann, wenn man eine Sicherheitsbehörde ist. Oder eben generell der Automatisierte-Abgleich-ID-Sitz wird ja mit eingeführt. Wir haben das vorhin eigentlich nur relativ kurz erwähnt, aber das ist natürlich für uns auch eine entscheidende Frage. Das ist ja ein Trend, klar, wir sind ja nur seit Jahren, dass da irgendwie die Datensammlung des Staates ausgebaut werden. Hier ist es eigentlich so, dass sich kaum Mühe gegeben haben, das noch irgendwie zu begründen.
Also vor allem halt nicht nur für irgendwelche kriminellen oder Abgleich mit kriminellen Datenbanken, sondern es geht halt zum Beispiel auch darum festzustellen, wenn du halt falsch gepackt, also Ordnungswidrigkeiten falsch packen, zu schnell fahren. Und wenn du irgendwie dessen verdächtigt wirst, kann die Polizei sagen, wir wollen jetzt mal irgendwie online auf diese Daten zugreifen, die du halt eigentlich dazu abgeben musstest, um deinen Ausweis überhaupt zu kriegen.
Und das sind sogar noch mehr als nur die Verkehrsordnungswidrigkeiten, das soll erweitert werden. Zum einen auf den ganzen Bereich Gefahren, Abwehr, kennen wir ja schon. Es ist sozusagen immer sehr wichtig, aber auch auf sonstige Ordnungswidrigkeiten. Das war doch einigermaßen erschreckend, denn es gibt eine ganze Latte an Ordnungswidrigkeiten, so Schmutz hinwerfen, Hund nicht anmelden, all diese Zeug, die jetzt plötzlich auch noch dazugehören, wenn man eben diesen Online-Abruf machen will.
Aber es ist doch super, es ist doch viel einfacher, es ist doch ganz praktisch, es ist doch toll.
Ja, was ich bloß vielleicht mal ein bisschen als Position, als Statement geben würde, ist es doch ein bisschen, weil die Sache ist immer, es wird so, die Daten, es ist irgendwie das, ich würde es zu Angst machen, einerseits schon, dass im Prinzip jede Daten, die irgendwo rumliegen, schon als Bedrohung empfunden werden und andererseits Daten einfach mal zwangsweise genommen werden, weil sonst, ich weiß nicht, was passiert, wenn man den Personalausweis ablehnt oder...
Nee, du kannst den Personalausweis nicht ablehnen. Also du musst ein gültiges Dokument haben und das ist entweder der Reisepass oder der Ausweis und dann kannst du sagen, nein, nein, nein, will ich nicht, aber du wirst ihn haben müssen, weil es ist...
Ja, sonst wäre ich schon eingeliefert oder weiß ich nicht.
Na du brauchst ihn doch einfach, wenn du zum Beispiel ein Konto aufmachen willst, dann nur Mietvertrag unterschreibst, also du brauchst dieses Dokument in Deutschland einfach, also eins von beiden.
Also das ist ja nicht zufällig, dass es da Staate draus gibt, denn das ist halt ja auch ein hoheitliches Dokument. Und man kommt im normalen Leben, also wenn man jetzt noch nicht versucht, sich irgendwie so legal in Deutschland rumzudrücken, man kommt nicht drum rum, denn einige Rechtsgeschäfte kann man ohne schlicht nicht mehr machen. Also Bank ist halt so typisch.
Mietertrag, gutes Beispiel.
Ja, manche Vermieter machen zwar nicht alle, aber in der Regel wollen die auch einen Ausweis nehmen. Manche beim Handyvertrag.
Genau, für alle möglichen Dinge musst du einen Ausweis haben. Also da führt irgendwie kein Weg dran vorbei.
Mein Problem ist eben genau das Hoheitliche. Und dagegen kann man vielleicht nicht viel tun. Aber wenn es jetzt irgendwie, sagen wir mal, private Pässe oder irgendwas geben würde, dann könnte sich einfach jeder selber raussuchen. Und irgendwie, dann könnten nicht einfach irgendwelche Melder einfach mal, ups, wir haben hier Daten wirklich.
Ja, aber das ist jetzt eine sehr zusammen konstruierte Theorie, weil natürlich braucht der Staat als quasi als Herrscher des Landes, in dem du lebst, muss sich um dich kümmern und da kann nicht jeder irgendwie seine Ausweise ausgeben. Das ist Quatsch. Aber ich gebe dir recht in dem Moment, wo du sagst, man kann schon mal über den Punkt nachdenken, warum gibt es das eigentlich alles und sich einfach tiefer in die Materie einlesen.
Man kann vor allem auch mal, man kann mal was überlegen, für alle Gelder, die sich jetzt an irgendwann einen machen müssen. Man kann überlegen, das abzuwählen, weil derzeit ist das noch optional und man kann einfach sagen, nein, wenn eine überwiegende Mehrzeit das macht, wäre das eine tolle Sache, denke ich.
Ja, also das auf jeden Fall, wenn man halt noch die Wahl hat, dann zumindest schon mal die Wahl auch wahrnehmen und dem Staat damit zeigen, dass man nicht damit einverstanden ist, dass er diese Daten wirklich sammelt und dann irgendwo hinstellt.
Okay, danke dir, der nächste ist am Telefon ist Oliver. Hallo Oliver, guten Abend. Das ist zu hören.
Ich hab meinen Ausweis schon auch mit Singerabdrücken.
Uh, erzähl mal.
So einen richtig neuen elektronischen Ausweis?
Ja, ja. Also ich bin so ein Early Adopter. Also ich hab das beides gebraucht.
Ein Early Adopter, wie du das gelernt hast.
Ich wollte Dinge haben. Und ich hab mich da schon so ein bisschen vorbereitet, dass ich mal ein paar abwachsen lassen. Das Foto hab ich dann machen lassen. Sehr geil. Drei Monate so richtig spriefen lassen. Und shapeen, also dass das Gesicht so ein bisschen verformt wird. Ich bin eigentlich relativ dick und dann bin ich auf einmal wieder schlank oder das Gesicht ist länger gezogen. Dann hab ich meine Brillenbügel nach vorne gebogen, dass ich auf einmal siegelohren hab. Also ich weiß nicht, man sieht das schon irgendwie.
Du hast aber wirklich immer A dafür, subversiv. Das ist aber schön, da bist du nicht mal notiert. Ja, gerade in Bayern, wo sie ja bei der Polizei über 300 von diesen Car-PCs haben, also diese ausgestatteten Polizeivagen, die später deinen Ausweis auslesen sollen.
Aber an der Stelle Oliver, du kannst gleich weitermachen, an der Stelle der Einwurf von mir oder die Frage, wenn ich irgendwie hingehe und mir einen Bart wachsen lasse und mir die Ohren nach vorne schiebe und so weiter und so fort, da kann niemand sagen, ich hab sie die letzte Woche aber gesehen, sie sehen ganz anders aus, oder? Oder wir haben hier ein altes Ton von ihr?
Na ja, ich muss mich halt selber wieder hätten, damit ich dann wieder so ausschaue wie auf dem Bild.
Das ist ja toll.
Also ich brauchte eine gewisse Vorlaufzeit.
Hat dann dein Foto gleich funktioniert, also haben sie es gleich akzeptiert?
Das war überhaupt kein Problem.
Und die Finger?
Das war so richtig so im Fotostudio. Ja, ich hab die Wand gestreichelt. Also ich hab so ein bisschen verputzt und wir sehen uns an der Wand.
Wollt ihr euch mal ein bisschen benehmen, so bei derselbe Tisch der Umfeld?
Ach, er hat mit uns gemeckert, weil wir so viel lachen. Einfach nicht irritieren lassen.
Das ist ja auch wirklich zum Lachen, wenn es nicht zum Meinen wäre. Und dann hab ich mir gedacht, also um eben fast noch die Krone aufzusetzen, muss ich irgendwas, ich hab da mal was gehört, ein paar Hagelfeile und über die Fingerkuppen. Und ich dachte, also die Geschichte mit dem So und So Kreuz, das geht ja nicht, aber ein Nummerenteilchen. Also ich hab das halt mal so ein bisschen gemacht. Ich hab mir gedacht, ich darf da auch nicht übertreiben, sonst steh ich da stundenlang und effektbar im Grunde genommen. Ich hab beide Zeigesinger aufgelegt und wahrscheinlich machen beide das Nummerenteilchen schön.
Konntest du den Bild schon nicht einsehen? Hast du nicht gesehen?
Nee, aber ich hab ihn danach gesagt. Sie wissen schon, dass ihr Rechner so da steht, dass ich hinten dran USB-Stick einstecken kann. Ich hatte dann schon ziemlich verwirrt. Habt ihr nicht verstanden.
Was meinst du eigentlich mit Nummerenteilchen?
Ja, ich hab mit der Nagelfeile dann morgen, bevor ich dahingegangen bin, noch so ein bisschen rumgefeilt. Das sollte dann so, also zweimal rechts, zweimal vertikal, zweimal horizontal.
Oh man, mir geht ja echt gerne ein Foto davon.
Ja, ich weiß ja nicht, was dabei ausgekommen ist. Also ich kriege ja kein Foto von meinem Fingerabdruck.
Naja, aber du kannst ja wohl irgendwie mit deinem Reisepass ins Meldeamt gehen und sagen, du möchtest jetzt mal die Fingerabdruckbilder sehen. Also du gibst ihnen halt einen Reisepass und sie legen ihn auf das Gerät und müssen dir zeigen, was da für Daten drauf gespeichert sind.
Wir haben das schon häufiger gemacht, denn alle Meldeämter halten dies vor. Wir haben uns ja zum Beispiel, gibt ja einige Menschen, die haben sich unsere Schäuble-Attrappe auf die Finger geklebt. Und wir sind in die Meldeämter gegangen und haben dann auch die Bildschirme fotografiert, um beweisen zu können, dass da wirklich ein Schäubleabdruck drauf ist. Das kannst du auch tun und dir ein schickes Foto machen von deinen Abdrücken.
Ja, das habe ich mich da nicht so getraut, weil ich gedacht habe, wenn ich da nochmal hinkomme, vielleicht behalten sie mich gleich.
Ach komm, du warst doch so cool mit deinem Bart. Dann kannst du da wohl auch mal ein Foto machen.
Wir hätten das gerne.
Du kannst doch nach Berlin kommen, dann machen wir das für dich.
Nach Berlin? Da war ich noch nie. Das wäre noch viel gefährlicher.
Stimmt.
Der Witz war das, dass ich dann probiert hab, so ein bisschen Diskussionen anzufangen. Nach dem Motto Freiheit kann verteidigt werden, dadurch, dass sie beschränkt wird.
Das kam bestimmt nicht gut an.
Nee, das war komisch. Zuerst waren drei Leute da. Ich hab dann auch schon überlegt, wo der Knopf ist, weil auf einmal waren fünf Leute da. Ja, so schlimm war es nicht. Es standen alle vor mir. Aber ich kenne die Leute. Ich bin öfters eine kleine Gemeinde. Ich hab dann schon probiert, so ein bisschen zu diskutieren. Es gibt diese Geschichte mit diesen Hollerit-Karten, wo vor x Jahren schon mal eine Volksstehlung gemacht worden ist. Irgendso ein Bösewicht hat es dann benutzt, weil da auch die Religionszugehörigkeit benutzt worden ist. Also auch gespeichert worden ist. Und ich hab solche Argumente probiert anzubringen und hab danach auch eben auch erzählt, was ist denn. Also es hat geheißen, ja, aber das ist ja alles sicher. Und das kann ja niemand auslesen. Und dann hab ich gesagt, wie ist das im Ausland? Und wenn dann diese Daten rücktransferiert werden. Und die Leute waren mehr als beratungsresistent. Also die wollten das eigentlich gar nicht. Ich meine, das ist ja klar, wir sind Beamte und die müssen ihren Job machen.
Aber im Endeffekt hast du schon problemlos deinen Pass dann gekriegt.
Naja, natürlich ist irgendwie so ein Meldeamt ja auch die falsche Stelle. Die Beamten können dann wirklich in der Regel nichts dafür. Und sind auch oft mit der Technik selber ziemlich überfordert. Aber dass die Bürger ihrem Unmut da Luft machen, finde ich schon richtig. Ich habe mich darüber sehr geärgert, dass der IT-Direktor im BMI kürzlich auf so einer Veranstaltung sagte, es gebe überhaupt gar keine Probleme auf dem Meldeamt. Es läuft alles wie geschmiert. Das ist nicht so, denn wir hören immer wieder die Geschichten. Das sollte das auch sagen, dass Ihnen das nicht gefällt. Und wenn Sie Glück haben, müssen Sie die ganze Sache wieder einrollen.
Das war ganz eindeutig, dass mir das nicht passt, weil ich gesagt habe, das ist meiner Meinung nach einfach nicht sicher. Es ist auch meiner Meinung nach eine Unverschämtheit wegen Generalverdacht usw. Für mich persönlich ist es so, gerade mit dem Foto, ich habe da eben so Sachen gesehen aus London, was da eben schon Software soweit ist, dass man einfach innerhalb von Bruchteilen, von Sekunden also diese Kontur oder das biometrische Bild zu bestimmten Daten zuordnen kann. Und es geht ja nicht nur darum, dass wir irgendwo unsere Fingerabdrücke hinterlassen, sondern dass wir irgendwo spazieren gehen und die wissen, wer wir sind.
Also das ist natürlich irgendwie die Träume, die sie nachher wirklich alle haben, dass du halt mit den Daten von den Personalausweisen dann halt alle Leute auf der Straße verfolgen kannst. Das funktioniert derzeit noch nicht, aber...
Es ist nicht wirklich mehr ein Traum. Immerhin machen, also der 1 zu N-Abgleich mit den 4 Millionen Datensätzen, die in der ARFIS-Datenbank sind, der ist schon gefordert. Also es ist nicht mehr so, dass wir über eine Zukunft von in 10 Jahren reden.
Olli, weil wir müssen jetzt Nachrichten machen, ein Wort vielleicht noch... Ein Wort vielleicht noch an dich als Abschluss. Wärst du kein First Adopter, hättest du jetzt das ganze Theater nicht. Aber du musstest es ja alle vorne weg haben.
Ich freu mich ja drauf. Ich nenne das ja irgendwie so Personalausweis-Hacking oder so was. Ich sag mal, ich mein, für mich ist es so, die wissen eigentlich nicht, wie ich ausschaue. Und wenn ich unbedingt meinen Ausweis brauch, dann muss ich mich halt wieder verkleiden, damit ich Spaß und so weiter habe.
Oder du kannst den Chip deaktivieren, dann hat sich das eh erledigt.
Ich hab mir überlegt, ob ich das nicht anders machen soll. Ich lass ihn jetzt noch so wie er ist und dann reise ich aus. Und dann tu ich ihn deaktivieren und vielleicht darf ich da nicht mehr einreisen.
Viel Spaß bei den Clowns. Servus nach Bayern.
Tschau. Die Popkom. Kommt. Vom 8. bis 10. Oktober. Da ist Fritz wieder das Radio zur Popkom. Und präsentiert das Popkom Festival. Jede Menge gute neue Musik in Berlin. Zum Beispiel neue Musik mit den Labels Cityslang und Wichita. Get well soon.
Die Bundesregierung hat ein 3 Milliarden-Hilfspaket für die deutschen Krankenhäuser auf den Weg gebracht. Mit dem Geld könnten in den nächsten drei Jahren 21.000 zusätzliche Pflegekräfte eingestellt werden, sagte Gesundheitsministerin Schmidt. Den Klinikbetreibern reicht das nicht. Sie sehen die flächendeckende Versorgung und Arbeitsplätze in Gefahr. Die Krankenkassen kritisieren, dass nur die Versicherten für das Milliardenpaket aufkommen müssten. Alle sieben Vorstandsmitglieder der KfW-Bank sind wegen Untreue angezeigt worden. Das teilte die Staatsanwaltschaft in Frankfurt am Main mit. Die KfW hatte der US-Bank Lehman Brothers 350 Millionen Euro überwiesen, obwohl das US-Institut zu diesem Zeitpunkt schon zahlungsunfähig war. Den beiden suspendierten Vorständen werden nach KfW-Angaben ihre Bezüge von insgesamt 600.000 Euro weitergezahlt. Wer sich beruflich verbessern und aufsteigen will, soll besser gefördert werden. Die Bundesregierung hat dafür heute die Regelungen zum Meister-Bafig geändert. In Zukunft bezahlt der Staat bei erfolgreicher Abschlussprüfung fast die Hälfte der Kurs- und Prüfungsgebühren, bisher ist es knapp ein Drittel. Außerdem sollen neben Handwerkern und anderen Fachkräften jetzt auch Altenpfleger und Erzieher bei der Fortbildung finanziell unterstützt werden. Der republikanische US-Präsidentschaftskandidat McCain will seinen Wahlkampf wegen der internationalen Finanzkrise unterbrechen. Außerdem wolle er das für Freitag geplante Fernseh-Duell mit seinem Rivalen Obama verschieben, sagte McCain in New York. Die neuesten Meinungsumfragen haben ergeben, dass der demokratische Kandidat Obama offensichtlich von den Turbulenzen auf dem US-Bankensektor profitiert. Obama käme derzeit auf 52 Prozent der Stimmen, der Republikaner McCain würde dagegen nur 43 Prozent erreichen. Hertha BSC hat das Achtelfinale des DFB-Pokals verpasst, die Berliner verloren am Abend bei Borussia Dortmund nach Verlängerung mit 1 zu 2. Mit den aktuellen Temperaturen potzt es am Neuropin 10 Grad, Wittenberg, Angermünde 11, Frankfurt 12, Cottbus 13 und in Berlin sind es derzeit 11 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es stellenweise bewirkt, in einigen Gegenden gibt es aber auch einen sternen, klaren Himmel. Regnen soll es heute Nacht aber nicht. Es bleibt also überall trocken. Das Thermometer sinkt heute Nacht bis auf 6 Grad. Morgen wird es tagsüber wieder sonnig, ohne Regen und das bei ziemlich Müllen 18 Grad. Vier Meldungen immer noch. AC, nördlicher Berliner Ringrichtung, Dreieck-Schwanenberg. Zwischen Dreieck-Haveland und dem Kreuz Oranienburg fährt ein Schwertransporter, den könnt ihr nicht überholen. A114, Zubinger-Pankow statt auswärts zwischen schöner Linda-Straße und dem Dreieck-Pankow liegen Gegenstände auf der Fahrbahn. Dort solltet ihr eure Augen also besser offen lassen. Und dann noch zwei Mellons im Stadtverkehr Berlin. A100 statt in Richtung Wedding. Zwischen der Albuinstraße und dem Hohenzollerndamm ist wegen Bauarbeiten die linke Spur gesperrt. Und A115, A115-Zubinger-Nutetal statt auswärts Richtung Dreieck-Hotztam. Zwischen dem Dreieck-Funkturm und dem Hüttenweg ist die rechte Spur gesperrt. Dort wird gebaut. Ansonsten allen, die noch unterwegs sind, eine gute Fahrt.
Und wir möchten euch natürlich darum bitten, auf allen Straßen, auf denen ihr unterwegs seid, sowohl in Berlin als auch in Brandenburg, als auch da, wo ihr sonst Fritz hört, die Augen generell offen zu halten, ist besser.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBW.
Und wenn im Radio 100, 1, dann Fritz in Eberswalde.
Blum, die Zeitsprechstunden.
Die Frau, die das Lied von Gollum gesungen hat, ist jetzt wieder da mit einem neuen Album. Abimi heißt es, das neue Album von Emeliana Turini. Davon habt ihr gerade gehört. I heard it all before, was wunderbar auch zum Thema der heutigen Chaosradio Sendung passt. Wir reden über den elektronischen Personalausweis. Wir hatten auch schon als Thema den elektronischen Reisepass. Da haben wir ausführlich darüber geredet, wo die Risiken und Gefahren liegen. Und jetzt kommt der elektronische Ausweis und alles scheint von vorne loszugehen. Wir haben schon ein bisschen erklärt, wo die Probleme liegen, wie das Ding funktionieren wird. Und es ist das Stichwort gefallen, online-Abgleich. Das heißt, ich bin irgendwo unterwegs, zwischen hier Dorf und da Dorf. Und nein, Konstanze Schlüttenkopf, ganz anders.
Das wäre ja dieser automatisierte Abgleich. Aber der online-Abruf ist zu sagen die Möglichkeit, online, also irgendwie über das Netz, auf diese Daten in den Meldebehörden zuzugreifen.
Kann ich das als Privatmensch auch?
Nee, das ist nicht vorgesehen. Das soll natürlich irgendwie hoheitlich bleiben. Das ist auch so geplant. Das haben sie eingeführt zum Reisepass. Da war es erst mal so, dass wenn die zuständige Ausweisbehörde eben oder die Paßbehörde nicht erreichbar ist, also etwa an den Wochenenden und nach den Öffnungszeiten, dann konnte dieses Online-Abruf-Verfahren gestartet werden. Jetzt haben sie sich gesagt, ist eigentlich überhaupt nicht so eine tolle Idee, wenn wir jetzt das Personalausweisgesetz machen, dann schreiben wir da gleich mal rein, da kann jetzt immer online zugegriffen werden. Auch so durch die Hintertür wird da plötzlich diese neue Regelung eingeführt. Und zusätzlich, was ich vorhin schon erwähnt hatte, eben jetzt nicht nur für Verkehrsaordnungswürdigkeiten, sondern auch gleich noch zur Gefahrenabwehr und für eben sonstige Ordnungswürdigkeiten. Das war so ein Kritikpunkt, wo wir uns eigentlich wundern, wo sie plötzlich mit diesen Forderungen da wieder herkommen.
Also sie hatten halt bisher schon immer die Möglichkeit, wenn sie ein Gesicht zu einer Person haben wollten, halt irgendwie zu sagen, wir brauchen das, dann haben sie halt irgendwie einen Brief bzw. einen Fax gekriegt und haben das angeglichen und waren halt glücklich. Was sie jetzt tun und was die große Gefahr ist, sie können es halt wirklich automatisiert und irgendwie ohne großartige Gründe machen. Das heißt, irgendwie sie klicken auf den Knopf und haben gleich irgendwie 1000 Bilder und das ist halt irgendwie wirklich die Gefahr, dass halt einfach dann, dass halt so vereinfacht wird, dass es halt einfach wirklich missbräuchlich benutzt werden wird.
Es geht ja auch um die Erkennungssysteme, denn sie haben ja nicht eher so ein Datenblatt, was aus einem Fax fällt mit einem Gesicht drauf, sondern ist natürlich ein digitales Bild, was man noch weiterverarbeiten kann und das hat die Gefahr.
Und halt auch dieser automatische Abgleich ist halt schon, dass sie alle Leute, die sie erst mal gegen diese eine Person abgleichen, halt schon unter den Verdacht erst mal stellen, dass die eine Straftat begangen haben, was hat ja irgendwie rechtlich auch Problematisches.
Naja, und weil wir beim Reisepass jedes Jahr wieder gefragt haben, was eigentlich uns der ganze Spaß dann insgesamt kostet und wir bis heute nicht wissen, denn die Bundesregierung hat einfach keine Kostenkalkulation gemacht, bis heute nicht, fängt dieser Spaß natürlich wieder jetzt an für den elektronischen Personalausweis. Und da die Kommunen doch einige Summen draufgelegt haben für den Reisepass, hat jetzt der Bundesrat gesagt, also so jetzt aber nicht, jetzt soll es so sein, dass bei dem Ausweis die Kosten des Dokuments, also die derjenige, der beantragt trägt, tatsächlich auch die Kosten decken sollen.
Was heißt das? Was kostet der Ausweis dann? Ist das schon klar?
Das ist noch nicht klar. Aber auf jeden Fall hat der Bundesrat die Bundesregierung aufgefordert, das alles vorher offen zu legen. Da sind wir natürlich gespannt, ob wir diese mal ein bisschen neue Zahlen bekommen, denn wir haben einfach keine von Reisepass.
Also zum Thema offenlegen, was halt beim Reisepass war, ist halt so, dass sie zum Anfang relativ offen waren mit ihrer, mit ihren Informationen, also jetzt mal abgesehen vom Geld, aber dann halt als Kritik aufgekommen ist, halt relativ schnell zurückgerudert sind. Es gab halt wirklich Aussagen vom BMI, also von Schili damals, der seinen Untergehenden verboten hat, über dieses Thema zu sprechen. Und beim Reise- beim Personalausweis haben sie halt draus gelernt, naja, gelernt wie auch immer. Auf jeden Fall war da gleich von Anfang an klar, es gibt keine Informationen. Also wir haben genau zwei Paper, also zwei Dokumente zu dem Thema, die auch so verschleppt rausgegeben wurden. Genau, die eigentlich auch teilweise nicht wirklich öffentlich sind, die wir halt irgendwie aus anderen Quellen haben, halt so vom BSI, vom BMI. Aber da ist halt die Informationspolitik noch viel eingeschränkter als beim Reisepass.
Und gleichzeitig wird aber auch verlockt, dass ja diesmal die Presse nicht so schlecht sei und offenbar die Idee mit dem Personalausweis ganz gut ankäme. Natürlich gibt er auch keine großartigen Informationen. Wer hat das gesagt? Der IT-Direktor Schallbruch wieder, mein spezieller Freund, der bei den Veranstaltungen, wenn man ihn da halt sprechen hört, hört sich das immer alles so an, als ob er problemlos läuft, überhaupt kein Sicherheitsproblem ist, obwohl er natürlich IT-Expertisen, die natürlich auch schriftlich gibt und die in den Expertenanhörungen im Bundestag ja auch verschriftlicht wurden, die gibt es, die sollten ihm auch bekannt sein. Aber er tut so, als wenn man ein super tolles, erfolgreiches Projekt jetzt noch mal für den Ausweis wiederholt.
Also echt eine Unverschämtheit schlechthin.
Aber die ganzen Kritikpunkte, die sowohl am elektronischen Reisepass als auch am elektronischen Ausweis von Datenschützern und von vielen anderen kommen.
Vor allem auch Sicherheitsprobleme.
Sicherheitsprobleme, rechtliche Probleme, moralische Probleme, alles was da so dazugehört. Finden die in irgendeiner Form Gehör? Gibt es da eine Entwicklung, dass die entsprechenden herausgebenden Behörden und Stellen sagen, ok, darüber denken wir nochmal nach oder ist jeglicher Ärger umsonst?
Das ist interessanterweise sogar so. Je mehr Kritik kommt, desto tauber werden sie. Also es gab halt diese Anhörung im Bundestag, wo eigentlich sämtliche Experten, also wirklich auch die eigenen des BSI, also der, der halt irgendwie beim Bundesinnenministerium dafür zuständig ist für die technische Analyse. Sie haben halt alle gesagt, da gibt es halt wirklich Probleme, ihr könnt das so nicht einführen. Und im Endeffekt haben sie es halt eingeführt, ohne großartig darüber zu studieren. Also da war es halt wirklich sehr deutlich, dass sie halt alle Experten, alle Expertenmeinungen einfach mal unter den Tisch gefallen lassen haben.
Okay, vielleicht abschließend nochmal die Frage, die viele Leute auch beschäftigt, die die Sendung heute gehört haben. Kann ich irgendwas machen, wenn ich diesen Ausweis nicht haben will?
Nein, man wird ein elektronisches Ausweisdokument haben müssen. Was wir empfehlen ist, sich vielleicht doch dieses funkenden, kontaktlosen Mikroships zu entledigen.
Oder ansonsten Ausweis jetzt noch beantragen und verlängern, dann gilt das Ding nämlich zehn Jahre.
Genau, beim Ausweis geht das ja.
Ihr seid erst mal für die nächsten zehn Jahre von diesem Thema nicht betroffen. Denn ab dem 1. November 2010, also im nächsten Jahr im November, ist der elektronische Personalausweis dann auch Pflicht und wird dann eingeführt. Das heißt nicht, dass ihr eure Ausweise umtauschen müsst automatisch, sondern wenn die Dinger ablaufen, dann kriegt ihr dann einen elektronischen.
Eine Sache wäre dann noch angekündigt, ist ja, dass in dem Zeitraum jetzt zwischen der Einführung und jetzt noch Probeläufe und auch größere Tests stattfinden. Da sind wir doch sehr gespannt drauf und wir hoffen doch sehr, dass aufgrund dieses super erfolgreichen Projekts die Ergebnisse dann auch öffentlich werden.
Wir werden euch auf jeden Fall über die weiteren Entwicklungen in Sachen elektronischer Ausweis informieren. Ihr könnt diese Sendung und viele andere natürlich als Podcast hören und euch in Ruhe noch mal reinziehen unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es auch alle anderen Sendungen, noch mal als Podcast zu hören. Da gibt es auch das Chaosradio Express, die etwas technischere Variante vom Chaosradio, was ihr auch hören könnt, was der Tim macht. Und alle weiteren Infos rund um den Chaos Computer Club. Und damit würde ich jetzt gerne das Buch um den elektronischen Ausweis zumachen und noch ein paar andere Sachen ansprechen, die noch vor der Tür stehen. Nämlich zum einen ist Blinkenlights da und es kommt auch noch ein Datengarten.
Also, Tim war schon mal das richtige Schlagwort. Es gibt wieder Blinkenlights, leider ganz schön weit weg. Und zwar so fast auf der anderen Seite des Wert-El-Wert-El-Wert-Balls.
Aber es gibt ja ein Internet.
Es gibt Internet. Genau, also Tim und ein paar andere Leute von uns sind gerade in Toronto und bauen dort irgendwie zur Nuit Blanche Blinkenlights auf. Und zwar diesmal auf zwei Häusern sogar. Also das ist immer ein bisschen besser als beim letzten Mal.
Die kurze Quereinstiegsgeschichte nebenbei. Was ist Blinkenlights?
Blinkenlights kamen das erste Mal vor fünf, sechs Jahren in Berlin. Haben im Haus des Lehrers hinter jedes Fenster, also wer das Haus des Lehrers kennt, am Alex, irgendwie dieses große, schöne alte DDR-Gebäude mit 144 Fenstern, haben hinter jedes Fenster einen Scheinwerfer gestellt, die ganzen Scheinwerfer verkabelt und irgendwie zum Rechner gebracht und haben praktisch jedes Fenster einzeln an- und ausschalten können. Also was man dann tun konnte, es hatten so kleine Kurzfilme abspielen, man konnte Pong drauf spielen, das heißt man konnte auch anrufen und halt dieses alte Computerspiel mit den zwei Balken, die sich links und rechts bewegen und den Ballländer mithin hüpft. Man konnte Liebesnachrichten übertragen.
Ach, wir sollten mal empfehlen, dass der geneigte Zuhörer bei der Suchmaschine seiner Wahl einfach mal blinken, Lights eintippt und dann wird er Filme finden und bei YouTube und...
Also es ist im Wesentlichen viel mehr als nur ein paar bunte blinkende Lampen, die irgendwelche Muster angeben.
Also es war auch sehr erfolgreich, die Toten Hosen zum Beispiel haben ein Video, irgendwie ein Musikvideo damit gedreht oder da drin und das gibt es jetzt wieder. Sie sind gerade beim Aufbau, soll fertig sein am 4. Oktober, aber sie sind halt inzwischen schon, also fast fertig, hat er mir gestern erzählt, das heißt irgendwie da kann man sich dann auf jeden Fall freuen, mal irgendwie Web Stream anklicken und dann mal ein bisschen zu gucken.
Blinken Lights.
Es ist Blinken Lights, also wie blinkende lichter.net und da findet man alles, was man schon immer wissen wollte.
Sehr schön. Kompliment an dieser Stelle immer wieder an Tim, die sich so abgefahrene Geschichten ausdenken.
Ja, wir sind irgendwie glaube ich im CCC alle Blinken Lights, das ist einfach schön.
Datengarten.
Ja, wir haben in Berlin wieder einen Datengarten, auf den wir verweisen wollen, wenn ihr aus Berlin und Umgebung kommt. Und zwar am 16. Oktober, also noch vor unserer nächsten Sendung hier bei Fritz. Und zwar im Berliner Club, im CCCB, in der Marienstrasse 11 in Mitte. Da kann man um 20 Uhr das Thema Weltraummedizinforschung hören. Wir haben Dr. Birgitta Ganser eingeladen und sie wird uns da auf den neuesten Stand bringen und einen Überblick über das Gebiet der Weltraummedizin bringen. Da sind wir schon ziemlich gespannt. Ich habe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Ahnung über Weltraummedizinforschung, aber danach sind wir vielleicht alle schlauer.
Also Datengarten ist nichts für kleine Botaniker, sondern eine Vortragsreihe zu...
Na ja, Vortragsreihe würde ich es nicht nennen, ist eher so. Wenn wir interessante Themen haben, dann findet es statt. Und man kann gleichzeitig vielleicht auch mal den Berliner Chaos Computer Club kennenlernen.
Wir haben noch ein Thema total vergessen, und zwar das Wochenende vorher am 11. Oktober ist natürlich die große Freiheit hat Angst Demonstration.
Genau, weil ihr die Schnauze voll habt von den biometrischen Gesichtsbildern, von der Vorratsdatenspeicherung, von der Kennzeichnung. Jedenfalls ist die schöne Demo. Wir hoffen auf tolle Wetter und auf ganz viele Besucher am 11. Oktober.
Genau, also kommt einmal vorbei, sagt euren Freunden Bescheid, kommt irgendwie und zeigt dem Staat, dass ihr irgendwie mit seinen Maßnahmen nicht einverstanden seid.
Genau, so und zu allerletzt haben wir natürlich jetzt noch einen Hinweis, den wir am Anfang der Sendung schon mal gemacht haben. Wir möchten euch auffordern heraus zur Wahlbeobachtung, wenn am 28. September in Brandenburg gewählt wird. Und wer wissen will, welche Gemeinden, der klickt einfach mal auf ccc.de. Da ist auch eine Liste von den zehn Gemeinden. Und wer sich irgendwie motivieren kann, der soll sich an uns wenden, nämlich an wahlcomputer.de und in der Mail schreiben. Und zum Beispiel ein bestimmtes Wahllokal und Stadtansagen, wo er gerne beobachten möchte. Denn wir wollen versuchen, alle diese, jetzt sind glaube ich 283, Wahlcomputer zu beobachten, also eine vollständige Abdeckung von Brandenburg zu machen.
Wobei die Vergangenheit gezeigt hat, dass Wahlcomputer eine relativ unsichere Kiste sind.
Genau, wir werden vielleicht sogar mit der Piratenpartei da zusammenarbeiten. Also es gibt noch andere Organisationen, die da mit beobachten. Und wir hoffen, dass wir die Wahllokale alle abdecken können. Die Hacker kommen.
Okay, das war's. Wir drücken die Daumen. Euch eine gute Nacht. Danke fürs Zuhören. Für eure Beteiligung an dieser Sendung. Nochmal zu hören geht das Ganze unter chaosradio.ccc.de. Da gibt es auch die Vorschau für die Themen der nächsten Sendung. Wir sind dann Ende Oktober wieder da. Hier geht es jetzt weiter mit Smith & Smart im Night Flight. Und das letzte Stück des Abends kriegt Charles Hamilton, Produzent aus den Staaten, der einen sehr amüsanten Rap gebastelt hat aus dem Sound des Windows Media Player. In diesem Sinne, das war's Chaos Radio.
Bis denn.
Ciao.